SPEAKER_01: Hello, and welcome to our
traveling game, game four of
SPEAKER_01: Sparks of the Past. Last game,
while there was two split-ups, one group
SPEAKER_01: went to go talk to the
Underworld and send some incriminating evidence
SPEAKER_01: to a SolSec operative that
might help out in the grand scheme of things,
SPEAKER_01: but they wanted to be as
separate as they possibly could. To meet the
SPEAKER_01: Underworld people, they had to
go to a A drug den where while they were
SPEAKER_01: there, they began to have the
pad of Mercer
SPEAKER_01: be triggering with a fine
location so they were able to run away and not
SPEAKER_01: get caught by the police. And
that was Group 1. Group 2 decided to go to
SPEAKER_01: TransStar and see what it
would be like in the TransStar exclusion zone.
SPEAKER_01: And when they got there, they
realized that they could have a TransStar
SPEAKER_01: day and become employees of
TransStar. While they went, they underwent a
SPEAKER_01: bunch of tests. Different
people got different positions, and many
SPEAKER_01: people became loaders. One
person, though, was able to actually get
SPEAKER_01: a full-on into the executive
group, where she is a now authorized
SPEAKER_01: manager of a department in a
junior executive team, and you have been
SPEAKER_01: told that the group that you
are managing is you're managing some aspect
SPEAKER_01: of naval control. You are all
staying in her
SPEAKER_01: sweet apartment, which gives
you guys a little bit more money, and the
SPEAKER_01: idea is that you are working
five days on and two days off, so you are
SPEAKER_01: able to still do some of your
hijinks in town if you need to. You no
SPEAKER_01: longer have identity veils,
but because you're Transire employees, who
SPEAKER_01: the hell cares? And you have
one month
SPEAKER_01: To be able to solve the
scenario of if you want to stay in Transtar or
SPEAKER_01: not, because after one month,
you have to sign multi-year contracts. So,
SPEAKER_01: in this one month is the time
you have to deal with that. Is there
SPEAKER_01: anyone who would like to bring
up something I did not note, just for
SPEAKER_01: clarification
SPEAKER_00: or eludication? Okay,
SPEAKER_00: so...
SPEAKER_01: You guys spend your night in
the suite after your tests. And the
SPEAKER_01: next morning at 630, all of
your
SPEAKER_01: badges begin to have a small
green flash on them.
SPEAKER_01: And if you touch the green
flash, a prerecorded communicator says,
SPEAKER_01: Welcome to your first day at
Transtar. Your new job and mission starts
SPEAKER_01: today. With your next day of
adventure at TransStar, please, in
SPEAKER_01: one hour and 15 minutes,
please arrive at the Dock 6-2.
SPEAKER_00: Thank you. Have a TransStar
day. I love your
SPEAKER_00: TransStar voice.
SPEAKER_02: It cracks me up.
SPEAKER_03: I'm going to TransStar all
over this day.
SPEAKER_03: What does that mean? Oh, my
God. And I pulled up
SPEAKER_01: a map on one of our
SPEAKER_03: terminals. Sorry, go ahead.
SPEAKER_02: I was like, oh, Alan's on it.
Then I said, oh, isn't he going to be
SPEAKER_02: late? Then I said, never mind.
SPEAKER_03: Could I pull up a map of the
compound and just
SPEAKER_03: identify where that
SPEAKER_01: dock is?
SPEAKER_00: Yeah, it's about ten minutes
of a brisk walk. Okay.
SPEAKER_00: Anybody else?
SPEAKER_01: Just because you wanted a
little bit of clarity. If we actually looked
SPEAKER_01: at the Capital page, let me
pull everyone here.
SPEAKER_03: Wrong one. Capital of Jordan.
And pull
SPEAKER_03: everyone.
SPEAKER_01: Okay. So you see how there is
a little piece in between the Transtar and
SPEAKER_01: kind of that Fort Raspir Naval
Annex? It basically is a slit. Between
SPEAKER_01: the down port, that is where
it's asking you to me.
SPEAKER_00: I am highlighting it with the
highlighter. So
SPEAKER_00: highlighted. I
SPEAKER_00: mean, it seems out of
character like we know this, but in character,
SPEAKER_00: I'll ask if anybody got a
different work assignment. No, but it sounds
SPEAKER_00: like we probably all got the
same.
SPEAKER_03: I actually need clarification
on this as well. If I remember
SPEAKER_03: correctly, we all got
varyingly different and hugely
SPEAKER_03: different staggered
assignments. One of us as an executive assistant
SPEAKER_03: gets a crazy apartment suite
that we can all live in. I am a loader.
SPEAKER_02: I believe Victor meant the
same assignment in terms of the same ship and
SPEAKER_02: not multiple locations.
SPEAKER_03: Oh, Suka. But thank you for
demonstrating why you're a loader. I did
SPEAKER_03: think he meant different jobs,
but sure. I even need to get my curse
SPEAKER_03: words right. I did not mean to
say this. I meant blit. Suka blot.
SPEAKER_03: And yes, that did mean...
SPEAKER_00: All to the same location, not
that we were all doing the same task. That
SPEAKER_00: is a good point of
clarification. Are we at the same location? He looks
SPEAKER_00: at his. We compare.
SPEAKER_03: Do we want to talk about the
future and what we want to do before we go
SPEAKER_03: to work, or not really? Oh, I
so want to, so much! Like, you know, the
SPEAKER_03: less time we spend here, the
better. The more time we spend getting
SPEAKER_03: innocence from random
inspector, the better.
SPEAKER_03: I don't know who is taking
lead on that. I know it's not me.
SPEAKER_00: I've been mostly thinking
about escort missions
SPEAKER_00: underwater.
SPEAKER_00: Okay, then. Well, I do think
that we've certainly
SPEAKER_00: got...
SPEAKER_03: Sorry, it sounded like someone
else was talking. No, no, no. I had just
SPEAKER_03: nonsense to say about how I,
too, want to talk about how we're going to
SPEAKER_03: get out of this situation.
SPEAKER_00: I don't have the answers,
unfortunately. Yeah. It does...
SPEAKER_00: Come on. You're highly robotic
to me.
SPEAKER_00: Same here as well. I thought I
was the only one playing a robot tonight.
SPEAKER_03: Such as the cruel fate of
Discord, the moment you
SPEAKER_00: started to clarify, he got
better.
SPEAKER_00: Discord always does that.
SPEAKER_02: Discord was doing weird things
to me the other day. I could see messages
SPEAKER_02: on my phone that were not
showing up on the desktop app. I feel like I
SPEAKER_02: couldn't talk to my friends
clearly.
SPEAKER_00: So, shocking. Discord doing
something funky. Who would have thought?
SPEAKER_00: We've lost forever. I think
it's moving from his phone to a computer.
SPEAKER_00: I think he's moving from his
phone to a computer.
SPEAKER_01: I will say, as people are
talking, there is a knock on the door,
SPEAKER_01: and when you guys open it,
there is boxes for each of you that have your
SPEAKER_01: TransStar uniforms. There even
is a uniform for the robot.
SPEAKER_02: Robot uniform.
SPEAKER_00: Robot gets clothes. Really?
They just give her a new decal? You
SPEAKER_00: know what? I mean, that's
probably actually what
SPEAKER_03: it is. It's probably like a
very light shawl that has branding all over
SPEAKER_03: it. Man, I was kind of hoping
for a new paint job.
SPEAKER_00: Is it? I think that's fine. Is
that fine? I don't know. New paint
SPEAKER_00: job? No? Yes? Cheat.
SPEAKER_03: Look, either way, talking of,
hey, how do we get out of this
SPEAKER_03: situation, he makes sure the
doors close, that we're back in a very
SPEAKER_03: private space, as he sort of
brings up, looking at Caspian,
SPEAKER_03: he's like, you were kind of
the one who, you know,
SPEAKER_03: Masterminded the actions that
we have going on outside of
SPEAKER_03: this place.
SPEAKER_00: How are we getting in contact
with this inspector of yours?
SPEAKER_00: Like, do we have to go back to
Lucen? Do we have to find him again?
SPEAKER_03: Do we have some... Is that the
first thing we kinda need to do?
SPEAKER_03: Establish a better form of
communication with InspectorGuy? Feed him
SPEAKER_03: info? That was the plan,
right? Feed evidence and
SPEAKER_03: info to Inspector to exonerate
us and, you know, persecute justice upon
SPEAKER_03: the sinners in the genetic
archive? That is plan?
SPEAKER_03: That is still plan? Yeah, we
did that. We've got that ball rolling. Oh,
SPEAKER_03: that's not a past tense thing.
You know. That's still the plan. Yeah, we
SPEAKER_03: just gotta...
SPEAKER_00: Get more evidence with which
to feed him. Okay, where do we get more
SPEAKER_00: evidence? Uh, we can work on
that after our
SPEAKER_00: shift today. That's not the...
SPEAKER_03: Fine, fine! He seems... He
frustratedly starts to put on this uniform.
SPEAKER_02: I can appreciate that you're
not excited to be a loader, but it's the
SPEAKER_02: only thing that's keeping us
safe right now. If we go out there with our
SPEAKER_02: faces, we're immediately going
to be picked up and thrown into the who's
SPEAKER_02: gal and never see the light of
day. Trust me on that.
SPEAKER_00: He's just putting on the
uniform.
SPEAKER_03: You know, one thing you and I
can keep an eye out for today is any kind
SPEAKER_03: of power converters
SPEAKER_02: or hookups that might allow us
to recharge the veils. So that's
SPEAKER_02: something we can keep an eye
out for.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah, absolutely. I support
that.
SPEAKER_00: Well, speaking of our shift,
SPEAKER_03: I have no idea if any of us
are going to be working together. I'm sure
SPEAKER_03: we should just kind of find
that out in assignment. This location, do we
SPEAKER_03: go?
SPEAKER_00: Well, they told us yesterday
we're going to be on the same team. I
SPEAKER_00: wonder how.
SPEAKER_03: I am, as begrudgingly as I
must say it, I am interested to see how that
SPEAKER_03: will work out. I guess it's
time to have a trans star day. And
SPEAKER_03: he says that with all of
the... His
SPEAKER_03: facial expression is exactly
what you think when he says it, so
SPEAKER_03: monotone.
SPEAKER_00: Just glower it. That's great.
SPEAKER_00: I imagine most of you get
dressed
SPEAKER_01: in your uniforms. People who
have past combat training can bring their
SPEAKER_01: weapons, but do remember you
are going to be on a submarine, so a lot
SPEAKER_01: of big slug weapons may not
want to go through soft hulls. Oh.
SPEAKER_03: As the sergeant of security,
I'm going to wear my armor.
SPEAKER_03: Yeah, I mean, if we know that
we are, if that's where we're going, like
SPEAKER_03: this isn't like a first day
we're doing an orientation. Hey, no, we're
SPEAKER_03: doing the submarine mission.
He's bringing everything. He's bringing the
SPEAKER_03: carapace. He's bringing the
shotgun. It
SPEAKER_03: is a Navy shotgun. It is
tailor-made to do just this. He's bringing all
SPEAKER_03: of it. He's bringing all of
his equipment for combat. So that's what
SPEAKER_03: he's preparing for.
SPEAKER_02: I just would like some
clarity. You're going to fight the submarine?
SPEAKER_02: Like, what are you fighting?
SPEAKER_03: Those who try to board
submarine? Those who are outside submarine that
SPEAKER_03: we must go fight? That is
probably something that will be on the
SPEAKER_03: submarine, too. EV suits. That
will be good review. Great fun. I think
SPEAKER_03: what she's saying is, as our
direct superior, like, 17 levels up, maybe
SPEAKER_03: it's not a great idea. I'm
bringing all of my stuff. We were explicitly
SPEAKER_03: told that we are here to
interact with bandits. I am bringing all of the
SPEAKER_03: shit to kill bandits. As the
head of security, I concur.
SPEAKER_02: Yeah, I mean, that's not my
jurisdiction at that point. I'm just saying
SPEAKER_02: the guy who pushes boxes
around is going to show up loaded to the teeth
SPEAKER_02: is maybe not the best look,
SPEAKER_03: but... Well, that's not what
we're doing today. We're not loading boxes
SPEAKER_03: today. Yes, you are.
SPEAKER_01: I just want to be clear. The
only people who are allowed to carry
SPEAKER_01: weapons are those who actually
have passed the military thing and did
SPEAKER_01: not fail.
SPEAKER_03: See, you didn't clarify that.
SPEAKER_03: I will admit to my
misinterpretation, you said
SPEAKER_03: combat training, he is combat
trained. Failing in the assessment that
SPEAKER_03: they had, okay, that makes
sense. No, he's wearing his loader equipment.
SPEAKER_03: If that is all he is permitted
to wear, he's wearing his loader
SPEAKER_03: equipment.
SPEAKER_01: You easily can lock stuff up
in the suite, but... A
SPEAKER_01: random loader carrying big,
big guns. And you could give your gun to...
SPEAKER_02: I was just about to say, if
anybody has a specific gun that I really
SPEAKER_02: like, I can throw it on. I can
carry that with me with my shit.
SPEAKER_03: Yes, you should.
SPEAKER_00: Yes, Caspian.
SPEAKER_03: I will be armed
SPEAKER_00: for a thief. Yes, bring my
Navy shotgun.
SPEAKER_00: It is a great shotgun. Even
the lethal shells,
SPEAKER_03: they will bounce. They do not
punch whole. They do bounce. It's very
SPEAKER_03: fun. I mean, sure, do whatever
you want, but I'm really
SPEAKER_03: hoping we're not going to need
to get into it. Oh, it is going to be an
SPEAKER_03: interesting prospect to how we
interact with the bandits. They are for
SPEAKER_03: sure employed by the Delphine
fellow, especially because they are going
SPEAKER_03: to be... They're dolphin,
eco-terrorist, not bandits.
SPEAKER_03: That was in the briefing they
gave us. Motive, tactics, goals.
SPEAKER_03: Yes, that leans them even
closer to being goons of Delphine.
SPEAKER_03: Delphine is an eco-terrorist
who is a dolphin. We are being potentially
SPEAKER_03: out on patrol trying to find
eco-terrorists who are dolphins. So it is
SPEAKER_03: most likely Delphine.
SPEAKER_01: From criminal organization
to... So anyway, do I get a badge or a
SPEAKER_01: lanyard as a security guard?
SPEAKER_00: I would say all of your badges
extend in a lanyard fashion if you
SPEAKER_00: stretch them. Quick rule
SPEAKER_00: question. Do lasers penetrate
holes? Or is it just slugs?
SPEAKER_01: I would say a concentrated
laser attack would penetrate a hole. Okay.
SPEAKER_01: But if you're just missing one
or two shots, you should be fine. All
SPEAKER_01: right. I'll take both of our
guns. The big
SPEAKER_01: power, by the way, of you
being able to use lasers and other things
SPEAKER_00: is you could theoretically
shoot them in the water. Okay.
SPEAKER_00: A shotgun does not shoot very
well under the sea.
SPEAKER_00: Do you mean even in the
submarine? No, I mean with you guys in vac suits
SPEAKER_00: in the water.
SPEAKER_00: Fair enough. Is the submarine
going to have vac suits which I need to
SPEAKER_00: bring my own?
SPEAKER_01: No. You will use the ones in
the submarine because let me also explain
SPEAKER_01: the mechanic thing. Normal vac
suits actually can't survive
SPEAKER_01: fathom depths.
SPEAKER_00: Oh, okay.
SPEAKER_01: Because their intention is to
deal with the lack of pressure, not high
SPEAKER_01: pressure. So in the book,
there are vac suits that are considered
SPEAKER_01: for dangerous environments,
and those work. But theoretically, there are
SPEAKER_01: also just naval, like,
submersible suits
SPEAKER_01: that exist. At this tech
level, it is very similar to a vac suit, and
SPEAKER_01: we're going to roll vac suits
for them. But if you try to take this
SPEAKER_01: wetsuit with a helmet in
space, the lack of pressure would begin to make
SPEAKER_01: it expand greatly and
eventually pop.
SPEAKER_00: But in the pressure of water,
it holds everything together.
SPEAKER_00: Okay. Yep, thank you. Check,
check. Okay.
SPEAKER_01: Now that everyone has handed a
weapon that they want to hand to Cole,
SPEAKER_01: and you are getting—
SPEAKER_02: Well, I did want to clarify
that. As the cool guy executive, do I get to
SPEAKER_02: keep my gun, or do I have to
give that away as well?
SPEAKER_01: You have just a handgun,
right?
SPEAKER_02: Yeah, I have an officer's
revolver from the Navy as well.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah, that one's going to stop
you as well. And, like, they're not going
SPEAKER_01: to rip off the guns off of the
robot. Yeah, okay.
SPEAKER_03: Thank you.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah, it is much more, like,
if Alan was
SPEAKER_01: here, they're not going to be
cool with him bringing his minigun. Got
SPEAKER_01: it. Okay. As you
SPEAKER_01: all, as a looking fancy in
your new fancy Transtar uniforms...
SPEAKER_01: You are walking across the
courtyard. You go through these areas,
SPEAKER_01: eventually to the naval dock,
and you come up to the dock that has
SPEAKER_01: been represented by the
number, and there is a man
SPEAKER_01: standing outside of there.
SPEAKER_00: You can tell that he is
definitely looking for... Someone coming along
SPEAKER_00: we have not yet found.
SPEAKER_02: So not us? He's looking for
someone who's not us?
SPEAKER_01: No, no. Or you say he's
looking for us? He's looking. He doesn't know
SPEAKER_01: it's you. He's looking for a
large part.
SPEAKER_02: Okay, I got it. I thought you
meant, like, he saw us and was like,
SPEAKER_02: you're not, these are not the
droids I'm looking for.
SPEAKER_00: Got it.
SPEAKER_00: I guess I will walk up and
SPEAKER_02: introduce myself. I'll just
kind of put out my hand. I think what you're
SPEAKER_02: looking for is us. Oh, that
guy. I don't know if I
SPEAKER_02: have a—do I have a ring?
SPEAKER_01: You are Junior Executive
Manager of Naval Operations.
SPEAKER_02: I am. That's exactly what I
am. I am Junior Executive Emma Colbert. I
SPEAKER_02: think it's a pleasure to meet
you.
SPEAKER_01: I am Annette Valencourt. It is
a pleasure to meet you. You are all the
SPEAKER_01: new TransStar employees,
correct?
SPEAKER_02: That is correct, yes.
SPEAKER_01: So the submarine that we are
going to be on is we have lost a
SPEAKER_01: majority of our crew, not
through any negative activity, but a new ship
SPEAKER_01: was built and they decided to
separate the experienced crew that we had
SPEAKER_01: here. Allow you to come and
learn what is going on while they are then
SPEAKER_01: preparing another ship with
the experiences that they have.
SPEAKER_02: I was just going to say, are
you the executive
SPEAKER_02: officer? How should I address
you?
SPEAKER_01: I am the captain of the ship.
SPEAKER_02: Oh, well then it is for sure a
pleasure to meet you then and we would
SPEAKER_02: ask permission to come aboard.
SPEAKER_01: Absolutely. It is the TSS
Profondeur.
SPEAKER_00: It is an old archaic word for
depths under the sea.
SPEAKER_00: I'm sure it'll serve us well,
whatever it's called.
SPEAKER_01: I'm happy to also introduce
you to the rest of the crew. So you can hold
SPEAKER_01: your introductions until we
are all together, if you'd be so kind. Oh,
SPEAKER_01: of course. So he walks you
guys into the submarine.
SPEAKER_01: For characters that have a
large amount of
SPEAKER_01: physical traits, I would say
if you are plus
SPEAKER_01: three in endurance and or
strength, it's a little difficult
SPEAKER_01: to walk through these areas
because it's small. There are small openings
SPEAKER_01: and small hatches. It's not
going to physically stop you, but you're not
SPEAKER_01: going to be racing through
this until you have a few weeks under your
SPEAKER_01: belt of getting
SPEAKER_00: used to hitting your head and
the like. Man, there are people out here
SPEAKER_00: with bloods. Three stats.
SPEAKER_02: Well, I mean, I technically
have a three stat, but it is not to my body.
SPEAKER_02: I can walk through doors.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah.
SPEAKER_00: Only endurance and strength.
So... I am going to pull
SPEAKER_00: everyone to the ship.
SPEAKER_01: And he is walking you through
the access hatch, and he is taking you
SPEAKER_01: into the control room, and I
am going to
SPEAKER_00: show the four members of the
crew.
SPEAKER_00: Okay. So, Anita Valancourt, is
it happening?
SPEAKER_00: Is he single?
SPEAKER_02: Hey robot, you keep roboting.
SPEAKER_01: I got a fancy outfit, man. I
know what's up,
SPEAKER_00: man. The robot's AI is just
going,
SPEAKER_00: I will woo him with my new
outfit.
SPEAKER_01: So, now that everyone's eager,
he says, I'm Captain Valancourt. I was a
SPEAKER_01: member of the Jardinian Navy
for 20 years. I had done
SPEAKER_01: sub-operations for them and
helped build particular platforms that were
SPEAKER_01: necessary. And TransStar gave
me a financial opportunity that I could do
SPEAKER_01: in between a promotion cycle,
and I moved over to TransStar. Then the
SPEAKER_01: first woman comes up,
Malay-Fronteux, She is an
SPEAKER_01: engineer. She is carrying a
sensor in
SPEAKER_01: one hand and a welding tool in
the other. She says, I've been in this
SPEAKER_01: ship for quite a while. I have
fixed broken pipes. I have
SPEAKER_01: stopped, what is the word,
terrorist actions against us.
SPEAKER_01: If you need something repaired
or fixed, I'm happy to show you how it is
SPEAKER_01: done. And then the next guy
stands up, Remy Bouchon.
SPEAKER_01: He says, I deal with the
electrics, the sonar and sensors, and the
SPEAKER_01: communications that we have
here. A lot of the work I'm going to be
SPEAKER_01: doing is to get those of you
who are capable prepared on different
SPEAKER_01: consoles. And I'm going to sit
at the one that you're less skilled at
SPEAKER_01: until we can get you at a
level where we can start doing cycling
SPEAKER_01: training. And then the last
woman is there.
SPEAKER_01: She has a sawed-off shotguns
strapped to each of her legs.
SPEAKER_01: She is like, I am Sabine
Cardone. I am security and also diving
SPEAKER_01: operations. I imagine many of
you have not felt the deep pressures that
SPEAKER_01: we're going to be dealing
with, let alone fighting in Underwater
SPEAKER_01: suits, it's my job to get you
up to speed to both be able to defend what
SPEAKER_01: we need to and to be able to
start doing engineering repairs on the
SPEAKER_01: problems that we have outside
of the ship.
SPEAKER_00: And if anyone wants to
introduce themselves to the people, please.
SPEAKER_02: I will introduce myself once
again since now they're all assembled as
SPEAKER_02: junior executives. Emma
Colbert, it is a pleasure to meet all of
SPEAKER_02: you, and I look forward to
serving with you. I say that much happier
SPEAKER_02: than it came across right now.
I realize that my intonation was not the
SPEAKER_02: best. Sorry.
SPEAKER_01: You can also put a quick
reference sheet in the chat if people want to
SPEAKER_01: look it up. Oh,
SPEAKER_02: that is a great reference
sheet.
SPEAKER_00: I'll say hello warmly.
SPEAKER_03: We say what we do. Kiernan
does the same. Do I load chips?
SPEAKER_01: Is that what I do? You say,
I've been registered as a loader.
SPEAKER_03: Exactly.
SPEAKER_01: No, I don't say that.
SPEAKER_03: I just introduced myself. And
I'm like, I'm glad to be here. I can help
SPEAKER_03: out with whatever you need.
SPEAKER_01: Well, if he doesn't say what
he is... Fontera says, so
SPEAKER_01: are you security? Are you
equipment? I'm sorry.
SPEAKER_01: Everyone needs to know what
they can do on this ship. We can't have
SPEAKER_01: anyone that is literally just
breathing the air.
SPEAKER_03: Ah, so what I can do and what
I'm hired to do are two different things.
SPEAKER_03: But if you need help fixing
something, or I can take a gander, but I'm
SPEAKER_03: here for loading.
SPEAKER_01: He kind of smiles and, like, a
few of them look at each other. And if
SPEAKER_01: you're on turn, Bouchard said,
we both failed our tests and we're
SPEAKER_01: loaders, too. One could say
that we might have you start
SPEAKER_01: loading programs. Or we might
have another scenario where
SPEAKER_01: we're going to have you load
bullets in guns.
SPEAKER_03: And then load those cartridges
into opposing enemies' bodies.
SPEAKER_00: Yes.
SPEAKER_03: I'm Sergeant Caspian,
SPEAKER_01: by the way. Hi, Caspian.
Sabine gives you the nod.
SPEAKER_01: But Fiontura says, we
understand a lot of you are not going to be paid
SPEAKER_01: at the quality that you were
because of the TransStar tests. Our goal is
SPEAKER_01: to make sure that you are
useful to the ship and that you're then able
SPEAKER_01: to show the experience that
you've done in a month. And we can then get
SPEAKER_01: you either retested
SPEAKER_00: or just automatically
reassigned to a better scenario.
SPEAKER_00: That's pretty sexy. It's the
SPEAKER_00: famous Trendstars pitch that
brought us all to this fine career. Yep.
SPEAKER_00: Right. Kynan, hello there.
Sabine says, I thought it's because
SPEAKER_00: you're all criminals of
SPEAKER_01: the state.
SPEAKER_03: Yes, that too. We are all
criminals of the state and currently are in...
SPEAKER_03: What briefing did you get on
us? That was fun. Hi. That was it.
SPEAKER_01: Stay here and not get
arrested. That was the great opportunity.
SPEAKER_03: This was a great opportunity.
I did not think you would know. Hi there.
SPEAKER_03: Also, where's the mess hall? I
think we'd like to say alleged criminals.
SPEAKER_03: Okay, Dan still is in denial.
I'm sorry for Dan.
SPEAKER_02: I didn't shoot anyone, did
you?
SPEAKER_03: Not anyone who's actually
leveled against any of us? I mean... Why are
SPEAKER_03: we telling anyone? Why are we
even implying we shot anyone? We didn't
SPEAKER_03: shoot anyone. We didn't
assassinate a high-level government employee. We
SPEAKER_03: shot a lot of people who were
trying to kill us to cover it up. Okay,
SPEAKER_03: wait, are we just telling the
whole thing?
SPEAKER_01: If so, I shot someone.
Sabine's like, I think you guys should be a
SPEAKER_01: little less worried. I killed
my husband because he was
SPEAKER_01: abusive. And when I was going
to be registered to go to my trial,
SPEAKER_01: I knew that his uncle who
worked for the judiciary would make sure that
SPEAKER_01: I would go to prison for the
next 40 years. So I decided to have a train
SPEAKER_01: star day. They're all still in
the bargaining stage
SPEAKER_01: of grief of losing their old
lives.
SPEAKER_03: Okay, come on. I think I've
progressed pretty well, all right? I'm
SPEAKER_03: already chumming up with
Sabine. Sabine, I totally get it. I also have
SPEAKER_03: been shot multiple times by my
ex. It's... I think, actually, we're
SPEAKER_03: probably on the other end.
SPEAKER_00: I'm sure we'll get along just
fine. Relationships in the military are
SPEAKER_00: hard.
SPEAKER_01: Captain Valancourt says, the
fact that you're here at TransStar and
SPEAKER_01: you've passed the test mean
that you want to stay alive and keep things
SPEAKER_01: moving in your life. You're
not self-destructive individuals who merely
SPEAKER_01: want to destroy all your
opportunities. You're looking for solutions,
SPEAKER_01: and Transtar has a place to
get that. As long as you're able to be a
SPEAKER_01: value to the ship, you're
going to be respected
SPEAKER_00: by everyone. Fantastic.
SPEAKER_00: One thing, though, that goes
to Maru.
SPEAKER_01: So... While you are a
particularly combative robot,
SPEAKER_01: I do notice that you have
SPEAKER_00: gecko model feet. I attest to
SPEAKER_00: the first part. Most people
find me quite amicable.
SPEAKER_01: I guess what I'm trying to say
is, is your robotic body able to handle
SPEAKER_01: Under sea pressures.
SPEAKER_03: Yes, I should be fine. You can
challenge me on those tasks.
SPEAKER_03: Are you saying you may have
need for me outside of the ship?
SPEAKER_01: There are certain situations
that have occurred where if we have a
SPEAKER_01: problem, by the time someone
gets a suit on, gets pressurized and gets
SPEAKER_01: out, the problem gets worse.
If you can magnetically lock onto the hull,
SPEAKER_01: get over there and minimize
the problems, We can then do a final fix
SPEAKER_01: with everyone by the time
they're in suits.
SPEAKER_03: Yes. I was designed for outer
space, so I can handle atmospheric
SPEAKER_03: pressures between zero and
one. No. But yes, I should be
SPEAKER_03: able to adhere to the hull and
do most standard work, considering we do
SPEAKER_03: not go to abyssal depth.
SPEAKER_01: In the reactor room, there are
three plug-ins if you do need to have an
SPEAKER_01: energy charge.
SPEAKER_00: Oh, that sounds delightful.
SPEAKER_01: It should not be difficult for
us to make sure that everyone here is on
SPEAKER_01: point. On the wall, he
SPEAKER_01: points to a map that is
standing there. This is the layout of our ship.
SPEAKER_01: The ship of the Profondeur.
SPEAKER_01: Make sure that you understand
it. There's going to be a lot of times
SPEAKER_01: where you'll be called to do
something, and if you can't realize where
SPEAKER_01: that location is, you're going
to be there too late. We are going to be
SPEAKER_01: running in shifts, but nothing
that should be overwhelmingly difficult
SPEAKER_01: once you've had a day or two.
We will be 12 hours on and 12 hours off.
SPEAKER_01: Um, that should be fine. The
food is automatically processed, uh, food
SPEAKER_01: cubes with spice packets. Um,
it's something you get used to. Um,
SPEAKER_01: Bouchamp says, I'm a big fan
of the chicken cacciatore spice.
SPEAKER_03: Yeah. Kiernan wipes the back
of his hand on a
SPEAKER_03: suddenly very sweaty forehead.
Do they have the Sichuan sauce? Uh...
SPEAKER_03: Sabine says they do have the
Setch websites. Fuck yes! He fucking pumps
SPEAKER_03: the air. He is much more hyped
to be on this submarine.
SPEAKER_00: Oh.
SPEAKER_01: Now, the first issue that we
have to deal with is the
SPEAKER_01: Hadal research site has been
abandoned now for about two months
SPEAKER_01: after an attack by undersea
terrorists. We believe that there may be
SPEAKER_01: some valuable resources still
inside of it. We are going to be taking
SPEAKER_01: about a 10-hour drive to the
site. Once we get there, we are going
SPEAKER_01: to prep people to have their
first diving experience. I do
SPEAKER_01: recommend everyone take an
opportunity to learn the suits. We are going
SPEAKER_01: to investigate the site. We
are going to mark key places that we are
SPEAKER_01: going to try to get inside to
salvage
SPEAKER_01: materials. And we are going to
return to our next mission
SPEAKER_01: after we've been there for two
days. Any questions or concerns?
SPEAKER_03: I've spent time as a belter
and a salvager in space. That's where my VAC
SPEAKER_03: suits
SPEAKER_01: skills come from. The biggest
difference you're going to notice
SPEAKER_01: in a belter environment is you
are very much used to falling into
SPEAKER_01: the pressure. You do a slight
push off of a wall and you expect there to
SPEAKER_01: be a lot going forward that
you're now trying to react to. The
SPEAKER_01: difference of an undersea
scenario at something that is as low as Hadal
SPEAKER_01: is Every pressure point you
do, you're going to gradually lose momentum.
SPEAKER_01: You're going to have a push
directly off of the wall, and then you're
SPEAKER_01: going to get slower and slower
and slower until you're eventually just
SPEAKER_01: stagnant in the point. Never
let yourself be off of a
SPEAKER_01: wall or a pole or some
direction you can push off to. Even if it is just
SPEAKER_01: pulling on a cable, you want
to make sure that you always have some
SPEAKER_01: constant momentum or it could
take a job that would take you 15 minutes
SPEAKER_01: might take you an hour to get
back if you're just in the middle of a
SPEAKER_01: float session. We will be
dealing with depths of a point
SPEAKER_01: where it will be absolute
darkness. So those of you who don't have back
SPEAKER_01: suit experience or belter
experience, it is a psychological hop that
SPEAKER_01: you're going to need to be
into.
SPEAKER_02: Are there safety lines? You
mentioned a table, but are there safety
SPEAKER_02: lines?
SPEAKER_01: So we have safety lines up to
200 feet. There are many times that you
SPEAKER_01: will go in excess of that 200
feet. When you begin
SPEAKER_01: to start learning your skills,
definitely stay in the lines. As you
SPEAKER_01: begin to have more and more
experience, you will be able to disconnect
SPEAKER_01: from them and do the work you
need to do.
SPEAKER_02: Emma's probably fine with
that. Laura is not. Laura's having, like,
SPEAKER_02: the idea of being surrounded
by complete darkness is freaking me out.
SPEAKER_03: They explicitly tell you it in
the briefing, your mind immediately is
SPEAKER_03: going, what's that gonna be
like?
Yeah.
SPEAKER_02: I mean, Emma has a lot of
experience being in space. It turns out Laura
SPEAKER_02: does not.
SPEAKER_01: Now, one of the key things
that you should understand while we have a
SPEAKER_01: falling sea floor directly
from the city of Jardin for about four miles,
SPEAKER_01: it then falls into a deep
chasm. This chasm will
SPEAKER_01: take specialized gear. The
profunder can get to the bottom of the chasm
SPEAKER_01: with minor damage. There are
certain aspects that we will maybe have to
SPEAKER_01: go in there as it is a key
place where the terrorists hide.
SPEAKER_01: Hadal is one of the lighter
location bases. And undersea
SPEAKER_01: base, Elyon, if we do get to
stop there, is a domed
SPEAKER_01: micro city base where there's
about 250 active personnel. You will
SPEAKER_01: be able to walk around there,
be able to breathe air, be able to have a
SPEAKER_01: meal that isn't a food cube.
Relay station 932
SPEAKER_01: is the main communication hub
in this area. It is able to transmit
SPEAKER_01: to all the different ships
here, and through that relay we are able to
SPEAKER_01: still maintain communications
all the way up to orbit.
SPEAKER_01: Those are the key kind of
things on the map as it kind of points out on
SPEAKER_01: the naval map. Anyone have any
questions or concerns?
SPEAKER_02: I did want to know if you
could potentially clarify, you've mentioned
SPEAKER_02: these terrorists multiple
times now, why are they terrorizing?
SPEAKER_02: Do we understand what their
message is other than just violence, for
SPEAKER_02: violence sake?
SPEAKER_01: They are definitely a scourge
of society that is
SPEAKER_01: removed from Okay. Okay. Okay.
SPEAKER_01: I didn't want to necessarily
put names on it because one person's pirate
SPEAKER_01: is another person's freedom
fighter.
SPEAKER_00: Very true.
SPEAKER_01: They do have supplied aspects
of very powerful
SPEAKER_01: undersea suits and a majority
of them are already pressure locked at a
SPEAKER_01: point where they can operate
under most sea conditions but not the
SPEAKER_01: surface. Because if we went to
that deep and everyone
SPEAKER_01: adapted to that, it could take
us a week to readapt
SPEAKER_00: to surface air. Okay.
SPEAKER_00: Okay.
SPEAKER_02: I mean, you always want to
know your enemy and what can happen.
SPEAKER_01: The primary weapons that they
use is they have micro-propelled
SPEAKER_01: harpoons with explosive tips.
All right. It is normally
SPEAKER_01: enough to compromise a vac
suit or to damage a ship that
SPEAKER_01: you eventually have to flee
with in those strikes. Sure.
SPEAKER_03: Yeah, Kiernan will raise his
hand slightly and just ask, is there
SPEAKER_03: a... Preferred weapon for
retaliation? Are there some
SPEAKER_03: armory or gunlockers that can
become standard issue in case of a fight
SPEAKER_03: or something? You make it
sound like there is a very high likelihood
SPEAKER_03: that we will get attacked
while in VAC suits or while out and about. Are
SPEAKER_03: there operations that we will
be very vulnerable to attack?
SPEAKER_01: So we've had problems in
Handing out weapons to those who are
SPEAKER_01: not registered militants by
TransStar. In the vigor of
SPEAKER_01: some people responding, we've
had damaged equipment and we've had
SPEAKER_01: injuries amongst the crew.
SPEAKER_03: Totally understandable. To the
latter half of my question,
SPEAKER_03: are there going to be
operations where we are notably vulnerable? Are
SPEAKER_03: they gunning and going for
people in VAC suits that they find outside of
SPEAKER_03: the ship?
SPEAKER_01: Quite likely. That is why
almost every scenario you will have, you will
SPEAKER_01: have a member of Sabine's team
with you that is armed.
SPEAKER_03: Okay.
SPEAKER_01: You will normally have some
aspect of separation if they cannot Babysit
SPEAKER_01: every single one of you, but
you will normally have some defensive team
SPEAKER_01: with you during some work.
They will sit and be watching point while the
SPEAKER_01: loaders
SPEAKER_00: and the engineers are doing
the work.
SPEAKER_00: Okay. Now, for those of you
SPEAKER_00: who have also not had
incredible
SPEAKER_01: space experience, there is
going to be a Aspect of claustrophobia
SPEAKER_01: that you will gradually get
within your first week or
SPEAKER_01: two. The air is going to have
a taste to it that you're not used to.
SPEAKER_01: The ship's movement is going
to be a little weird for you. The ringing
SPEAKER_01: in your ears of the pressure
is going to be a little weird to you. If
SPEAKER_01: you're finding that occurring,
You need to communicate to your
SPEAKER_01: executive officer as soon as
possible. There are methodologies that we
SPEAKER_01: can do to put you on limited
duties until you can acclimate. We can make
SPEAKER_01: sure that you are signed off
for a three-day to get your sea
SPEAKER_01: legs back. What we need to
know is that you're not just suffering alone
SPEAKER_01: trying to push your way
through a scenario and you're
SPEAKER_00: Lack of being 100% gets
someone else killed.
SPEAKER_00: They're not very meaningfully
at that.
SPEAKER_03: Understood. Kiernan's got a
knowing look on his face, not just looks
SPEAKER_03: around, kind of makes sure
everyone else is
SPEAKER_00: hearing that.
SPEAKER_01: Sabine is going to show you to
the crew quarters. Oh. And you guys can
SPEAKER_01: get settled while me and
Fortier are going to
SPEAKER_01: get the ship gradually moving.
Once you get all of your gear away, feel
SPEAKER_01: free to come to any station
where one of us is at and we will begin to
SPEAKER_01: walk you through some basic
observations.
SPEAKER_00: Thank you. Yes, sir.
SPEAKER_01: Now, If anyone wants to now
give me a naval tactics, because I know a
SPEAKER_01: lot of you bought naval
tactics.
SPEAKER_00: Indeed. I have
SPEAKER_00: a good naval tactics. I'm
almost home. I'm out on the doggy walk of the
SPEAKER_00: evening. If anyone wants to
roll for me. Josh,
SPEAKER_00: it says you privately rolled
some dice. Whoa.
SPEAKER_00: What is the default to that?
SPEAKER_03: I got a 14. Looking to roll
him? Oh god, I have naval
SPEAKER_03: tactics. I checked my sheet as
a lark, but I totally do.
SPEAKER_02: Where is that located?
SPEAKER_03: Yeah, it's under tactics.
Lower right.
SPEAKER_02: Oh, there it is. I apologize.
Okay. Yes, you've got quite a bit of naval
SPEAKER_02: tactics.
SPEAKER_00: And if you want it, I bet with
all of our Navy backgrounds, most of us
SPEAKER_00: have it.
SPEAKER_02: Do you roll streak decks?
Like, what are we rolling on this?
SPEAKER_01: That's an average failure.
SPEAKER_03: I didn't really have any. I
mean, I rolled dice. People told me to roll
SPEAKER_03: dice, so I rolled. But, you
know, average failure.
SPEAKER_02: Is it education or intellect?
SPEAKER_01: It would be intellect,
primarily. Okay.
SPEAKER_00: Nice.
SPEAKER_01: Has it average success? And
Cole had
SPEAKER_00: a failure. Did you see what I
sent? I did not see
SPEAKER_00: anything you sent after Joth
probably rolled some dice.
SPEAKER_02: Because Joth privately rolled
some dice.
SPEAKER_01: I need you to make sure that
it's on public. Yeah, I don't know why, but
SPEAKER_01: I never change it back. It
automatically goes there. Did you make it
SPEAKER_01: public?
SPEAKER_03: Yes, last time. Now, enroll. I
just
SPEAKER_03: screenshotted you and sent you
my thing.
SPEAKER_00: I'll roll it again. Whatever.
SPEAKER_00: I just need to make sure that
we can see your stuff. That's it.
SPEAKER_01: Okay, so we're going to take
Josh's... Well, you actually got a... It's
SPEAKER_01: okay.
SPEAKER_03: I still got a 12, which is not
as good as the 14 that I got before.
SPEAKER_01: Well, one said exceptional, I
guess. I can barely read it. One was a 6.
SPEAKER_01: One's a 4. It's fine. You're
not going to get more data past a 4. Okay.
SPEAKER_01: So Josh is the top one. Oh,
no. Josh is the top one.
SPEAKER_01: So at Josh's level, you
realize there's way more space for more
SPEAKER_01: crew here.
SPEAKER_00: This is probably a section of
crew that could be up to 30 people.
SPEAKER_00: Yep. This is already a pirated
ship.
SPEAKER_00: Now, the people who had...
SPEAKER_01: One person had a two, and that
was... That was me, yep. So one of the
SPEAKER_01: things that you notice is in
the missile room, all of the
SPEAKER_01: missiles have been replaced.
SPEAKER_00: With almost like escape pods.
SPEAKER_01: So people can get into
basically the missile thing from some control
SPEAKER_01: panel inside of there. It will
shoot them out in a pressurized tube that
SPEAKER_01: will hold them in that
pressure until they're rescued by TransStar.
SPEAKER_00: Okay. Mm-hmm. Steinbach, one
SPEAKER_00: of the things that you
SPEAKER_01: realize is that there are
SPEAKER_01: things broken or things left
behind that
SPEAKER_01: seem odd. Like, you find a
guy's pictures of his family on
SPEAKER_01: one of the crew deck areas.
Yeah.
SPEAKER_03: But his face doesn't match up
with any of the crew that I've met.
SPEAKER_01: You also find, and by the way,
everyone knows from bottom up. So the
SPEAKER_01: person who had the four knows
what Annette got, and the person who had
SPEAKER_01: the one in the four knows what
Steinbach got. So there also was a
SPEAKER_01: mini-sub that has a huge part
of it
SPEAKER_01: ripped off.
SPEAKER_00: And it looks like it was
dumped basically back where it was, and it is
SPEAKER_00: completely destroyed.
SPEAKER_00: Completely destroyed beyond
any ability to mechanic to repair, without
SPEAKER_00: massive investment. Yeah,
basically imagine like a quarter of it was
SPEAKER_00: just rent off. Okay. Um...
SPEAKER_00: Yeah. So that's all what you
guys know is you're all kind of prepping.
SPEAKER_01: You guys get your stuff all
organized. You get everything kind of
SPEAKER_01: prepared. Next to your group
quarters, as you like lay down,
SPEAKER_01: there is a clock that appears
next to your bed as a digital readout to
SPEAKER_01: show which part of the 12-hour
term you're on. Everyone's
SPEAKER_01: 12-hour term is set Staggered,
so you will normally see
SPEAKER_01: someone during your entire
12-hour time, because one of you might see
SPEAKER_01: each other for two hours, and
they're just getting off shift, kind of
SPEAKER_01: thing.
SPEAKER_03: Oh my god. On rotation. Yeah,
who's on rotation with me? Who's my battle
SPEAKER_03: buddy?
SPEAKER_01: What I'm trying to imply is,
you'll be able to interact with all the
SPEAKER_01: characters, but imagine that
they are sleeping when you are not. Okay.
SPEAKER_01: Do they have me on a rotation
as well, or am I just on duty? Do they
SPEAKER_01: have you on a rotation because
they don't know you're charging shit?
SPEAKER_03: Oh, I tell them that once I'm
charged, I can operate for days. So I ask
SPEAKER_03: them to use me to their full
requirement.
SPEAKER_01: What is your non-combat skills
that you want to sell them?
SPEAKER_03: I have electronics,
SPEAKER_03: Recon and Naval Tactics.
SPEAKER_01: Your electronics is a generic,
right? You don't have a specialty, right?
SPEAKER_03: Right. I've got the green
asterisk next to Remote Ops.
SPEAKER_03: Okay. So, expert software.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah. They say that there is a
drone
SPEAKER_01: that they have. That they'll
have you at the drone station basically
SPEAKER_01: flying around to make sure
that they're not being followed in places
SPEAKER_01: they can't hear with the
sonar.
SPEAKER_03: Sure. Happy to use my talents
there.
SPEAKER_01: Perfect.
SPEAKER_00: Does anyone else would like to
ask for a very particular job or be
SPEAKER_00: trained under a particular
person? I think...
SPEAKER_03: I mean, I'll volunteer to load
up any... Non-crew member
SPEAKER_03: materials into crates to be
SPEAKER_01: offloaded at a future time. So
they're going to prepare you for Vax
SPEAKER_01: suit training. Do you have any
Vax suit?
SPEAKER_00: I do have Vax suit, yes. Okay,
so they're going to have you in the first
SPEAKER_00: dive. Can you all hear me? We
can now. Yeah, we can now.
SPEAKER_03: I do not want to speak
anymore. If you are, we now know why. I wouldn't
SPEAKER_03: mind being trained in anything
that you have an opening for, but
SPEAKER_03: otherwise, I'm pretty open to
doing tough-filling stuff. I'm kind of a
SPEAKER_03: jack-of-all-trades.
SPEAKER_00: Pick what you would like. They
put me in what? Pick what you would like.
SPEAKER_00: Pick what I would like.
Because they're like, a person who
SPEAKER_00: doesn't say what job they want
cleans latrines. Fair enough. Then,
SPEAKER_00: what are the options again?
There are four people who basically you can
SPEAKER_00: work under. You pick one of
those four people, and then they're going to
SPEAKER_00: assign you work. The
engineering
SPEAKER_00: tactician, I guess.
SPEAKER_01: Okay, so the engineer person?
SPEAKER_03: The male fournier.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah. She is going to be
showing you guys
SPEAKER_01: engineering power. If you guys
have an engineering power, great. If you
SPEAKER_01: do not, she is basically going
to start training you guys in engineering
SPEAKER_01: power.
SPEAKER_03: Okay. Kiernan would work under
Sabine for sure and definitely has a lot
SPEAKER_03: of Vaxu training. All right,
so where you guys need the most help.
SPEAKER_03: Above average with back suits,
but that's been in space. I know a little
SPEAKER_03: bit of Medic. Kind of okay on
mechanics.
SPEAKER_00: I'm going to be in sneaky and
scouting things, and I'm pretty good with
SPEAKER_00: computers. I just
SPEAKER_00: want to be clear. Yeah,
SPEAKER_03: so Caspian will go try to
train under Etienne of Valcourt.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah, that's what I would try
to do too. And
SPEAKER_00: then...
SPEAKER_00: Okay.
SPEAKER_01: So is that about right? Victor
and Saren are going to go out of the ship
SPEAKER_01: with Sabine. Emma and Cass are
going to
SPEAKER_00: work with the captain. And,
Zoe, what are you going to try to do?
SPEAKER_00: Well, I'm definitely going to
go out of the ship some The gate
SPEAKER_00: acclimated to using the
backsuit in the water. Okay, perfect.
SPEAKER_00: Okay.
SPEAKER_01: Now, we're going to start with
the people with Valancourt, and he is
SPEAKER_01: going to show some basic
aspects of piloting. He's going to show some
SPEAKER_01: naval recon of how you know
where you can see where you're going. I'm
SPEAKER_01: going to pull everyone to the
undersea map for a moment.
SPEAKER_01: And the Proconder is going to
be sailing to Hidal Research Site, and
SPEAKER_01: that is going to take them six
hours to get there. While they're doing
SPEAKER_01: that, he's showing you how to
physically move the ship. He's showing you
SPEAKER_01: how to read the sonar arrays.
And you notice very quickly that because
SPEAKER_01: they don't have enough people,
he is sitting on a
SPEAKER_01: large... He's not doing
anything close. So he knows from the sonar
SPEAKER_01: data that the ground is, let's
say... He's 600 yards
SPEAKER_01: away. He is not even getting
close to it, so he doesn't have to keep
SPEAKER_01: dealing with the sonars or the
pings. He can just keep sailing straight,
SPEAKER_01: and then he can deal with the
problems as they come along. You realize
SPEAKER_01: that they are doing good
handoffs. Who can do what? Because the
SPEAKER_01: activity of Working perfectly
on ProFunder would take a lot more people
SPEAKER_01: in communication. So as you
guys get better and you guys can start
SPEAKER_01: calling that data out, they
can do more. Like he could hide in the silt
SPEAKER_01: because you guys are going to
be able to constantly tell them the depths
SPEAKER_01: and things
SPEAKER_00: like that. Okay.
SPEAKER_01: As he kind of gets a little
closer, he's also going to talk to you guys
SPEAKER_01: a little bit more about the
terrorists. And he's like, while some of the
SPEAKER_01: terrorists are humanoid, they
also have
SPEAKER_01: a large amount of orcas with
them.
SPEAKER_02: That's not unsurprising.
SPEAKER_01: The orcas allow them to go up
and down to these areas that we cannot
SPEAKER_01: easily deal with the pressure.
And be able to
SPEAKER_01: bring large volumes of stuff
that they merely swallow and then cough it
SPEAKER_01: up when they get to their
underground rooms. That's kind of gross.
SPEAKER_01: Key leaders of the ORCA group
also have cybernetic rigs that allow them
SPEAKER_01: to rip metal Easily.
SPEAKER_00: If one can construe it, it's
almost a battle suit, but it's not meant
SPEAKER_00: for defense, it's only meant
for strength increasing.
SPEAKER_02: That's a little terrifying
when you're sitting inside a submarine, but
SPEAKER_02: it's understandable as well.
SPEAKER_01: The one other advantage we
have is Profound dirt can go faster than they
SPEAKER_01: can swim. Okay. How quick can
we get to speed, though?
SPEAKER_01: If we're willing to fully
alert everyone around us, we can reach full
SPEAKER_01: speed in about four minutes.
Okay. But the capsizing
SPEAKER_01: of the air behind us as we
move so quickly alerts anyone
SPEAKER_01: with sonic detectors in
probably a three-mile radius. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
SPEAKER_01: That makes sense. Most of the
time, we gradually move speed and not
SPEAKER_01: have... The incredible amounts
of sound that's being pushed through it.
SPEAKER_01: Now, this particular ship Was
a Jordanian
SPEAKER_01: naval vessel that was attacked
and damaged. They were able
SPEAKER_01: to link it back to Jordanian
naval base, but they did not feel it was
SPEAKER_01: valuable enough to fully
repair, so Transtar bought it, lifted it, and
SPEAKER_01: gave it a retrofit. But this
is about a 25, 30-year-old ship.
SPEAKER_00: That old in the grand scheme?
Yes.
SPEAKER_01: It's unlike spaceships that
are decades old where they're constantly
SPEAKER_01: dealing with interest
pressures, space and the pressure of a jump. But
SPEAKER_01: the profondeur has kept us
well for a while. We've had a few instances
SPEAKER_01: and accidents which have been
rough on the crew where we've had a Let's
SPEAKER_01: say some orcas hiding in the
silt as we came by. They jumped up and they
SPEAKER_01: ripped out parts of the hull.
We were able to lock off those particular
SPEAKER_01: locations until we were able
to move forward.
SPEAKER_00: But as long as the crew trusts
each other, we've been able to get
SPEAKER_00: through all the different
scrapes we've had. That's impressive with such
SPEAKER_00: a small career to be able to
accomplish so much.
SPEAKER_01: Thank you. But do remember
that we... We had double the crew before you
SPEAKER_01: guys came on. We separated the
crew so they could start training another
SPEAKER_01: site.
SPEAKER_02: At any point, will we be
taking on more standard crew or just
SPEAKER_02: us for now?
SPEAKER_01: After the month of your
observation time, I'm supposed to write a report
SPEAKER_01: if we feel that you should
stay in aquatics or if you should be
SPEAKER_00: recommended to another crew.
Understood. And it's not
SPEAKER_00: a demotion.
SPEAKER_01: It is Transdar wants to find
the place that everyone thrives.
SPEAKER_02: I did not interpret it as a
demotion. I interpreted it much more as a
SPEAKER_02: lateral shift in skill set.
Exactly.
SPEAKER_01: Some people can't handle the
sound.
SPEAKER_01: Those who are very much used
to vac suits in the depths of space have
SPEAKER_01: psychologically gotten to the
nothingness. There is a
SPEAKER_01: hum that you hear when you're
in a subsuit. You feel
SPEAKER_01: your own heartbeat inside your
ears and inside your skull as everything
SPEAKER_01: is pushing in on you.
SPEAKER_00: It is a psychological thing
that not everyone does.
SPEAKER_00: That's uncalculable tension.
SPEAKER_02: Again, that's Laura. I'm like,
there's a reason I don't go deep in the
SPEAKER_02: water.
SPEAKER_00: Does anyone want to ask him
any other questions regarding the next
SPEAKER_00: group?
SPEAKER_02: I do have a question for the
GM. Since he's teaching us Essentially
SPEAKER_02: piloting, I guess, steering. I
don't know. Is there an applicable skill?
SPEAKER_02: Because piloting and flyer
don't seem to really be applicable, but if we
SPEAKER_02: had to take...
SPEAKER_01: It counts as pilot small
craft.
SPEAKER_02: Okay. Okay.
SPEAKER_01: There we go, then.
SPEAKER_02: That answers that question.
SPEAKER_01: All right, thank you. Just so
everyone understands the mechanic, is
SPEAKER_01: every week of training on the
ship, Counts as an automatic week of you
SPEAKER_01: education prepping that skill.
SPEAKER_00: Okay. So after a month, you'll
have a point.
SPEAKER_00: Or a roll, rather.
SPEAKER_03: A roll for a point.
SPEAKER_01: Exactly. At the end of your
month, you guys will get a roll for whatever
SPEAKER_01: group you were in, and to
permanently get the skill is going to be the
SPEAKER_01: test of the roll.
SPEAKER_03: Sweet. It's an education test,
I believe.
SPEAKER_01: Yes, it's an education test
for everything except the vac suit and
SPEAKER_01: physical activities.
SPEAKER_00: The vac suits can be done on
an endurance roll.
SPEAKER_00: So the idea is whatever
SPEAKER_01: trait you would have done on
it, primarily it's education, you can
SPEAKER_01: basically try to learn it.
SPEAKER_00: Physical things that you learn
by road or activity, you can try to do
SPEAKER_00: with another stat. Okay.
SPEAKER_00: So let's go now to Sabine's
group.
SPEAKER_01: So Sabine takes all of you
guys to the kind of
SPEAKER_01: airlock area. She pulls you
into the first piece of the airlock. You do
SPEAKER_01: see some emergency suits
outside the airlock, but inside the airlock are
SPEAKER_01: much higher quality active
suits. She does the classic,
SPEAKER_01: have all of you used a back
suit before? Please raise your hand.
SPEAKER_03: Kiernan will raise his hand,
but he's looking at these suits very much
SPEAKER_03: with a dogged curiosity. He's
coming into this space very open to learn
SPEAKER_03: a new thing. He is very happy
to experience
SPEAKER_03: these novel suits.
SPEAKER_01: While you're used to very much
in a backseat scenario that if you have a
SPEAKER_01: little bit of failure, you're
going to be gradually spilling air for a
SPEAKER_01: while, that particular part of
undersea environmental suits
SPEAKER_01: are a lot easier as the water
pressure is going to sink in a lot of
SPEAKER_01: your valves and your setups.
So even a valve that's 70-80% correct will
SPEAKER_01: hold as long as you're not
being overly active. The second
SPEAKER_01: thing I want everyone to
realize is you are not going to be breathing
SPEAKER_01: oxygen most of the time we're
going to be doing our deep sea work.
SPEAKER_01: Oxygen at these levels and
pressures will cause conflicts with your body
SPEAKER_01: chemistry if you have not been
genetically modified. So we have the pink
SPEAKER_01: tanks here and we have the
blue tanks here. You're going to see a light
SPEAKER_01: on the wall. If that light
turns to red, you have to use the pink tanks.
SPEAKER_01: If it's on green, you use the
other tanks. The tanks for when we are
SPEAKER_01: deep have certain aspects of
helium to be able to push the oxygen
SPEAKER_01: through your body and not just
get crushed to not be useful.
SPEAKER_01: You'll notice that these suits
all have neck mics. As you begin to
SPEAKER_01: speak, it'll automatically
transmit you to your local team. If you need
SPEAKER_01: to have a private
communication on the side control panel, You're going
SPEAKER_01: to be able to see the buttons
to be able to control individual pieces of
SPEAKER_01: communication. Now, your
lights turn on automatically the moment that
SPEAKER_01: you're in the water. But that
first moment of darkness while they turn
SPEAKER_01: on is an alarming thing. They
are tap sensitive. So if you do
SPEAKER_01: need to turn off your lights
for some reason, all you have to do is hit
SPEAKER_01: it with your hand and they
will turn off.
SPEAKER_00: You can hit it again and they
will turn back on.
SPEAKER_00: Does everyone want to try to
get suit around themselves, or do you want
SPEAKER_01: to do partners?
SPEAKER_00: What do we want to do what?
SPEAKER_01: What did you say? Partners. As
Josh has emotional damage.
SPEAKER_01: Trauma. I think partnering up
is the smart way to go.
SPEAKER_01: She's going to work with Zoe,
because Zoe is trying to fit
SPEAKER_01: into a full-size human.
Environmental suit.
SPEAKER_00: And so, everyone, roll your
suit.
SPEAKER_00: You said roll our vac suit? It
kind of went funny there. With a boon.
SPEAKER_00: With a boon. Okay. I mean,
freaking Christmas. Ross, you are
SPEAKER_00: privately again. What?
SPEAKER_01: So that means that every
single one automatically, if I don't change it,
SPEAKER_01: is on... I rolled it, though.
Did you see I made a public one? Jesus
SPEAKER_01: Christ. Again, my private one
was better, but
SPEAKER_00: the public one was still
pretty good. You had better than a seven?
SPEAKER_00: What? Yeah, I think it was
like an eight. Let me check.
SPEAKER_00: Okay. Yeah, it was an eight.
SPEAKER_01: Okay. Everyone has been very
successful in getting their back suits on.
SPEAKER_01: As I mentioned in the other
group, you do notice, though, that it is a
SPEAKER_01: little weird that you still
have audible hearing. Even though you're
SPEAKER_01: hearing through your mics and
your communicators, you're also hearing
SPEAKER_01: the person in the room talk.
When normally you're in a vac suit
SPEAKER_01: scenario, that doesn't occur.
Once everyone's there and she's checked
SPEAKER_01: everyone's work, she gives a
thumbs up that all of your guys' work has
SPEAKER_01: been correct. And those of you
who are more engineer-y, she
SPEAKER_01: takes you to a toolbox that
you can strap to your back. And those of you
SPEAKER_01: who are more combat-y, she has
harpoon guns for you guys to
SPEAKER_01: fire.
SPEAKER_00: Oh, shit. I've got a base
level mechanic.
SPEAKER_00: People who are primarily
loaders should take the gear.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah, Josh, you're still on
private. What do you mean? You didn't get
SPEAKER_00: either of them?
SPEAKER_03: No, I'm seeing on the
screenshot you just sent me, Yeah, yeah, yeah. The
SPEAKER_03: first one was on private. I
think every role is automatically set to
SPEAKER_03: private for some reason on my
thing.
SPEAKER_01: Okay, right now, does it
currently have private highlighted?
SPEAKER_03: I would have to check a new
role, I guess.
SPEAKER_01: No, no, no. There's an
indicator right there where there's a globe and
SPEAKER_01: there is an incognito guy and
there's an eye with a scratch.
SPEAKER_03: There's a globe and an
incognito guy?
SPEAKER_00: On the picture you just sent,
Underneath the back suit.
SPEAKER_00: Blind to Game Master. It is
self-only public as character.
SPEAKER_00: Maybe I clicked that once by
accident. I don't know. The one you want is
SPEAKER_00: public as user. Yeah, that's
what I did. Okay. And that one's now
SPEAKER_00: highlighted, right? Yes. Okay.
Can you roll anything once just to make
SPEAKER_00: sure it doesn't hop over?
Sure.
SPEAKER_00: And that worked perfectly.
Okay. Okay. As long as that one stays
SPEAKER_00: highlighted with the globe, it
should be fine. Okay.
SPEAKER_01: She takes all of you to the
location. Now, do all of you also have a
SPEAKER_01: base electronics?
SPEAKER_00: Yes.
SPEAKER_03: Yes, I have electronic
sensors. I have electronic remote pumps.
SPEAKER_01: As long as you have base
electronics is all I'm worried about.
SPEAKER_03: Got a base.
SPEAKER_01: Okay. We live in the future.
SPEAKER_03: How could we not know a little
electronics?
SPEAKER_01: Well, you could be a
techno-barbarian shooting big minigens.
SPEAKER_01: Now, if you have base
electronics, you are able to use the onboard
SPEAKER_01: computer, which basically will
show the distance of everyone who
SPEAKER_01: has gone out with you at the
same time. Your communicators will
SPEAKER_01: communicate with everyone
there, and it will also say
SPEAKER_00: your distance from the ship,
but it doesn't say what direction.
SPEAKER_00: The same as all the individual
people.
SPEAKER_01: It'll say Sabine is 600 yards
away, but you don't know if that's the
SPEAKER_01: left or the right. You could
start going one direction and keep looking
SPEAKER_01: at it and see like... If she's
standing still, go the other way.
SPEAKER_01: But just so you have a concept
of what's being done. Now, the people who
SPEAKER_01: have engineering tool sets, on
your computer,
SPEAKER_01: it also shows the amount of
gas in your welding torches,
SPEAKER_01: and it shows the amount of
electronics you have for your automatic
SPEAKER_01: wrenches and socket sets. So
you can understand,
SPEAKER_01: basically, I've been working
on this for an hour.
SPEAKER_00: I don't have enough energy to
keep finishing the project in return.
SPEAKER_00: Okay.
SPEAKER_01: She begins to do some basic
drills for you guys to walk around the ship.
SPEAKER_00: I would say also that they
would have Annette's character also come out
SPEAKER_00: right now to have
SPEAKER_00: Bye. Okay.
SPEAKER_02: Good night. Oopsie. That never
happened to Patrick before.
SPEAKER_03: I know, he was like on a roll
and then...
SPEAKER_03: Discord decked him.
SPEAKER_00: I hope everything's okay.
Yeah, I hope his power didn't go out. The
SPEAKER_00: recording bot is still on,
though. Well, that's server-based.
SPEAKER_02: Yeah, that's a service you log
into. I still have power, and I don't
SPEAKER_02: live that far from them. So I
would assume we're on the same grid, but
SPEAKER_02: maybe we're not.
SPEAKER_00: Here, I'll text her.
SPEAKER_03: The completionist in me wants
the Arab to have its own power system.
SPEAKER_02: Yes. That's exactly what it
needs to have. It's only run by Jews. I'm
SPEAKER_02: obsessed with the Arab.
SPEAKER_03: I think they're awesome. No,
like,
SPEAKER_03: I was wild about the Erev
walking around Manhattan. I was like, look,
SPEAKER_03: there it is!
SPEAKER_02: There's the wire! We were
discussing how the Erev had its own power
SPEAKER_02: structure and that that's what
happened to you.
SPEAKER_01: What was the last thing people
heard?
SPEAKER_03: You were just about to say,
and then Annette comes along and then you
SPEAKER_03: poofed.
SPEAKER_01: Okay. So Annette, when you
come along, they're going to give you one of
SPEAKER_01: the computer packs that are on
the VAC suits. Okay. So you have a basic
SPEAKER_01: concept of the amount of
distance everyone is, but you still don't have
SPEAKER_01: direction in the Sea of
Darkness. Okay. And did people
SPEAKER_01: hear that if you're a tool
user, your battery
SPEAKER_01: percentages are on there?
SPEAKER_03: Yeah, I heard that.
SPEAKER_01: Okay, great. So can everyone
who's outside the ship give me either a
SPEAKER_01: pure dexterity roll or
SPEAKER_00: a dexterity athletics roll?
SPEAKER_00: Okay, dex athletics.
SPEAKER_00: Okay. And your role was
public, Josh. Yay! Wait, I'm not
SPEAKER_00: outside the ship.
SPEAKER_01: Oops. Yeah, no, yeah, they're
showing you how to do it, too. You're
SPEAKER_01: outside the ship, that's fine.
They're trying to have you with the team
SPEAKER_01: for now to understand the,
like, the commands and stuff if you lose
SPEAKER_01: communication, how to do hand
gestures.
SPEAKER_03: Oh, okay. Cool, cool.
SPEAKER_01: So everyone who succeeded was
able to Completely circumnavigate
SPEAKER_01: the entire sub. Everyone who
failed,
SPEAKER_01: they turned around or a wave
kind of pushed them. Or when they got to
SPEAKER_01: the bottom, they got a little
stuck in the ground. You're able to
SPEAKER_01: recover because you have
unlimited time, basically. But those who
SPEAKER_01: succeeded, you can tell that
they did it at a pattern while they can
SPEAKER_01: improve their time. They're
basically now seeing who's fast and who's
SPEAKER_01: slow when they get out there.
Sabine turns on the
SPEAKER_01: communicators to everyone and
says, I know some of you, it's your first
SPEAKER_01: time. Who wants to do drills
or who wants to get straight
SPEAKER_00: to work? Let's do some drills.
SPEAKER_00: I am happy behind my chair.
SPEAKER_01: So what Sabine does is she
takes out a flare
SPEAKER_01: and she throws it off away
from the ship. And
SPEAKER_01: she says, everyone who was
unable to circumnavigate it, you guys
SPEAKER_01: go get the flare. So the
people who did not succeed on the roll
SPEAKER_01: can roll either Strength,
Stamina, or Dexterity, whatever one is your
SPEAKER_01: highest.
SPEAKER_00: To try to get to the Flare
first.
SPEAKER_00: By Stamina, do you mean
Endurance? Endurance, yeah.
SPEAKER_00: I continue to fail my rolls.
Hey,
SPEAKER_00: the, uh...
SPEAKER_01: The robot starts kicking a
swim technique with a complete lack of care
SPEAKER_01: of the idea of pressure or
physical tiredness, and pushes off the ship
SPEAKER_01: and grabs the flare while
everyone else is trying to get a bit of
SPEAKER_01: momentum. And she kicks off
and pushes back. It's not
SPEAKER_01: fair, I'm basically a skidoo.
Mario, that is very
SPEAKER_01: successful. Now, what I would
like you to do is pick one of the people
SPEAKER_01: who is having difficulty, and
I want you to go get a rock off the
SPEAKER_01: ground, and I want you to try
to play catch with one of these people.
SPEAKER_01: It's important for you guys to
understand how things move when you throw
SPEAKER_01: them, and the weight
differences when you're down.
SPEAKER_03: Okay, well, I'll work with
Zoe, then.
SPEAKER_00: Okay.
SPEAKER_02: He doesn't break the glass of
his mask.
SPEAKER_01: Right. Zoid, can you roll
either Tactics, Naval,
SPEAKER_01: Recon, or
SPEAKER_00: a Physical Trait? Roll Recon.
SPEAKER_01: As the rock kind of falls into
a group of kelp, you are able to dive
SPEAKER_01: into the kelp, grab the rock,
and push yourself off with an aspect of
SPEAKER_01: success. Now, Victor, let me
show you
SPEAKER_01: a piece of your toolkit as she
walks you over to a side of the hull. As
SPEAKER_01: you come to this piece of the
hull, you do see that there is some
SPEAKER_01: scratches, like maybe they
skid against a rock or it was a peeling
SPEAKER_01: patch job of some other type
of repair. And she starts walking you
SPEAKER_01: through how to use the
underwater tool. Blow torches
SPEAKER_01: to weld it together. If you
would like to roll either a
SPEAKER_01: repair kind of skill or an
engineering skill, feel free.
SPEAKER_03: All right, I have mechanics,
which
SPEAKER_00: seems appropriate. Wait, so
who should be rolling this? This is Victor.
SPEAKER_00: Okay. Yay!
SPEAKER_00: Perfect.
SPEAKER_01: That's a great weld line for
especially down here. You're going to
SPEAKER_01: notice as you get deeper
dealing with different types of materials,
SPEAKER_01: you're going to need to change
the amount of air that you're feeding it.
SPEAKER_01: You'll find if you give it too
much air, it will merely bubble through a
SPEAKER_01: hole. If you give it too
little, you won't be able to
SPEAKER_00: pull your weld. Makes a
certain amount of sense.
SPEAKER_00: Now, Josh, were you a fighter
SPEAKER_00: or a loader?
SPEAKER_03: I think I was a loader.
SPEAKER_01: I should have gone to any
other test.
SPEAKER_03: Every other test, I would have
been done better. But yeah, I'm a loader.
SPEAKER_01: Now, over here, she takes you
to a pipe that you see
SPEAKER_01: underground, like underwater.
She pulls up one of the layers on the
SPEAKER_01: pipe, and you see bundles...
Can you click again on the
SPEAKER_00: map when you say over here?
Because I have my character sheet open. Did
SPEAKER_00: I what over the map? Did you
click on the map when you said over here or
SPEAKER_00: no? So never mind, continue
then.
SPEAKER_01: As she pulls up this layer of
pipe, you see all of this fiber optic
SPEAKER_01: cable with lights glowing down
through it. And she says, quite
SPEAKER_01: commonly, there will need to
be repairs or situations in here. You will
SPEAKER_01: find that the pipe is normally
going in between bases. If you find
SPEAKER_01: yourself entirely lost without
communication, you're going to want to
SPEAKER_01: follow the pipe until you
eventually get to a base or an outpost where
SPEAKER_01: you're going to be able to
communicate from. Right now, can you try to
SPEAKER_01: patch into this with
electronics and see if you can get an extended
SPEAKER_01: communication?
SPEAKER_03: I should do comms?
SPEAKER_01: Yep.
SPEAKER_03: Okay, because I have zero
comms, but okay.
SPEAKER_00: If you have better
electronics, you can use pure electronics if you want
SPEAKER_00: pure electronics.
SPEAKER_00: I mean, I have better remote
ops, but it's okay. I'll do comms.
SPEAKER_00: Okay, perfect. You connect to
it and you pick up a telenovela.
SPEAKER_00: There we go. So, are we all
feeling pretty good right now?
SPEAKER_01: There is a port on the outside
that we can refill our suits.
SPEAKER_01: Everyone go here, do a refill,
and we're going to go down to Hadal and
SPEAKER_01: we're going to look for a
particular gear that we can find.
SPEAKER_00: While that's occurring, I'm
going to go to the last person. And...
SPEAKER_00: Oh.
SPEAKER_01: Dan, I thought, was in the
engineering group. I was like, Josh, I
SPEAKER_01: thought you were the engineer,
not in the water.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah, I'm in the engineer. Oh,
this was the team that was going to the
SPEAKER_00: water. I thought the name
was... Mattel
SPEAKER_00: Fortier. Yeah, that's not who
went. I'm sorry.
SPEAKER_01: This is the Sabine team that
was all going in the water.
SPEAKER_00: Okay.
SPEAKER_01: It's fine. You're with the
Sabine team day one.
SPEAKER_00: Okay.
SPEAKER_01: Okay. So it's easier. It's
just two groups. We can just separate between
SPEAKER_01: the two groups. Okay. I'm
going to go back to the captain for a bit, and
SPEAKER_01: then we're going to have the
undersea team start actually doing some
SPEAKER_01: recovery. Okay. Captain
Valancourt is talking to Emma
SPEAKER_01: and Cass, and he begins to
kind of start showing you a bit about how
SPEAKER_01: You can start doing control
manipulation of
SPEAKER_01: like if someone shoots a
torpedo, you try to hack the torpedo's
SPEAKER_01: communications. He shows you a
bit about
SPEAKER_01: how you can overwhelm certain
things, like one of the weapons that they
SPEAKER_01: have, if the orcas get too
close, they keep pinging the sonar to
SPEAKER_01: overwhelm their ears.
SPEAKER_01: And as it's kind of going and
he arrives there, he stops the ship and he
SPEAKER_01: says, let me show you a little
bit more of what we have here. And he
SPEAKER_01: begins to show you some
logistic things. He shows the storeroom where
SPEAKER_01: the oxygen and the other
chemicals are being held. He shows you the
SPEAKER_01: radio room and there is plot
for
SPEAKER_01: people who have computers to
upload and download Messages and the like.
SPEAKER_01: He shows you a laboratory that
is kind of old and dusty, but you can
SPEAKER_01: tell that it was used before.
SPEAKER_02: Can you elaborate when you say
before, like before when there were more
SPEAKER_02: people, or even before that?
SPEAKER_01: It looks like it's been used
for at least three to four months.
SPEAKER_02: Okay, I'm just like, how dusty
does it get in a controlled environment?
SPEAKER_01: It gets pretty dusty because
of machine grit in the air.
SPEAKER_01: Okay. There is, like,
SPEAKER_01: even on a real sub, things
actually get fairly dusty.
SPEAKER_02: Okay. Yeah, I didn't know
that. I just was like, you're purifying the
SPEAKER_02: air all the time. I would
think that it wouldn't, but I've never been on
SPEAKER_02: a submarine.
SPEAKER_01: You also have to think that
when they're purifying the air, it's
SPEAKER_01: constantly diminishing
returns. So it's getting
SPEAKER_01: grittier and grittier as the
air kind of goes by.
SPEAKER_03: I went on a submarine earlier
this year with my kids. Towards the end, I
SPEAKER_03: freaked the fuck out.
SPEAKER_00: Oh, no.
SPEAKER_03: I was explaining to them how
tight it was and how long people were on
SPEAKER_03: the sub for months and months.
And then I realized how small it was. And
SPEAKER_03: I was like, can I push these
people out of my way to get off the sub?
SPEAKER_00: I mean, I held it together, so
they didn't realize I was about to die,
SPEAKER_00: but it was touching me.
SPEAKER_02: Good to know. Don't put Josh
back in a submarine.
SPEAKER_00: I think they must have
realized something, because my son said, there's
SPEAKER_00: more air up here, Papa. I'm
sorry,
SPEAKER_00: continue. Oh, you're good.
SPEAKER_00: So,
SPEAKER_01: Is there any questions that
you're going to ask him since you have
SPEAKER_01: private time with the captain?
SPEAKER_02: I will let him know that I do
have a particular specialty in
SPEAKER_02: communications, and so if ever
it comes into
SPEAKER_02: play, I can man the
communications station to try to run interference.
SPEAKER_02: That was previously my
specialty in my other life, shall we say.
SPEAKER_01: Do you have any knowledge of
sensors?
SPEAKER_00: I think I do, actually. Hold
on.
SPEAKER_00: Where would they be under?
Electronic sensors. Okay, just double
SPEAKER_00: checking.
SPEAKER_02: I have a one in sensors.
SPEAKER_01: Perfect. Because by
understanding communications and sensors, you can
SPEAKER_01: begin to understand the
intricacies of sonar. As you're listening on all
SPEAKER_01: these sound communications
back and forth, you can begin to understand
SPEAKER_01: how the sound bounces off of
everything. So he's saying you can put
SPEAKER_01: education points in either.
SPEAKER_00: Okay, cool. I get to be
underwater Uhura.
SPEAKER_00: Can you give me a comms role?
SPEAKER_02: Yeah. Comms intellect or comms
education?
SPEAKER_01: Comms intellect, because
you're
SPEAKER_00: not prepared for it.
SPEAKER_01: As you guys are leaving the
radio room, you do realize that there is
SPEAKER_01: group of communications that
are
SPEAKER_00: locked even from the captain.
Oh, interesting.
SPEAKER_00: You think with your comms we
could be fixed? Sure. Nice roll, Laura.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah, that was particularly
badass.
SPEAKER_02: I'm taking all the good juju,
because that's how I got to be an
SPEAKER_02: executive officer, too, was I
just rolled really well.
SPEAKER_01: Are you going to try to find a
way to stay behind? Do you encrypt them,
SPEAKER_01: or are you just going to let
them
SPEAKER_02: stay behind? Oh, I didn't
realize that was an option. Yeah, I'll be
SPEAKER_02: like, hey, I'd really like to
familiarize myself with this equipment if
SPEAKER_02: I can. I'm much more used to
spaceships, and while I see that there are
SPEAKER_02: similarities, there are some
differences that I would like to be
SPEAKER_02: familiar with before we're in
the heat of a situation.
SPEAKER_01: Of course. I'll stay here and
be able to poke at it a bit. I'll send
SPEAKER_01: Remy when we walk back up and
give you a little bit more details of the
SPEAKER_01: subscommunications.
SPEAKER_02: Thank you. I really appreciate
that.
SPEAKER_01: As you guys are going, you're
going to obviously try to be super fast in
SPEAKER_01: your hack? Yep. Okay. Can you
roll the intelligence? Now you can roll
SPEAKER_01: education or intelligence,
whatever you prefer for that electronics
SPEAKER_01: comm.
SPEAKER_00: I'm probably going to roll
education for comms.
SPEAKER_00: Damn. Damn.
SPEAKER_01: In a matter of a moment, using
some of your SolSec knowledge, It
SPEAKER_01: is Jordanian military
communications that
SPEAKER_01: there are living people in a
SPEAKER_01: particularly attacked location
and they're asking for an SOS.
SPEAKER_01: But the reason it is encrypted
is these people have
SPEAKER_01: data or military secrets where
none of their communications were allowed
SPEAKER_01: to be on an open band.
SPEAKER_02: Okay, so let me just clarify,
I understand that, right? So people who
SPEAKER_02: have secret information are
asking for an SOS, but it's being hidden
SPEAKER_02: from the captain?
SPEAKER_01: It's being hidden from anyone
who isn't Jardinian military.
SPEAKER_02: Oh, because we're on Transdar.
Yes. Okay, how did we acquire that
SPEAKER_02: information then? Was it just
put out on a broadband?
SPEAKER_01: Yeah, it was a broadband, but
it was encrypted. So only the Jardinian
SPEAKER_01: military had the codes.
SPEAKER_02: Oh, okay. I understand what's
going on now. Yes, I am a Hexor.
SPEAKER_02: Wow. Interesting. Okay. Okay.
SPEAKER_00: Laura, you have seen the first
two episodes of The Expanse, right?
SPEAKER_02: I have. Get a little holding.
SPEAKER_01: While you're doing that, so
you can think about it.
SPEAKER_00: Okay. Nass, what would you
like to do?
SPEAKER_00: Are you there, Colb?
SPEAKER_00: Can you hear me now? I hear
you now, yes. What would you
SPEAKER_00: like to do? We can now no
longer hear you.
SPEAKER_00: I want to continue the work in
the bridge, if possible. If I can do
SPEAKER_00: that again.
SPEAKER_01: Okay. He gets you up there.
He's showing you some piloting stuff as you
SPEAKER_01: guys are coming around. He
also,
SPEAKER_01: because you have a Gunner
Zero, he also shows you basically how to
SPEAKER_01: initiate the forward
torpedoes. The torpedo
SPEAKER_01: tubes.
SPEAKER_03: But they're now
SPEAKER_01: escape pods. Those are the
missiles, not the torpedoes. Oh, gotcha.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah. The missiles were like
ballistic missiles that they pulled out.
SPEAKER_03: Oh, gotcha, gotcha, gotcha.
See the surface missiles. Yeah. So do
SPEAKER_03: we have an armament of
torpedoes?
SPEAKER_01: We do. We have four torpedoes
that we are able to fire. They are
SPEAKER_01: quite expensive, so we
primarily use them to attack underwater
SPEAKER_01: caves that we see
SPEAKER_00: terrorist fleet in. Gotcha, so
SPEAKER_00: if the Orcas go into a cave,
you blow it up.
SPEAKER_01: Right, because they're going
to be faster than a torpedo, and almost all
SPEAKER_01: naval ships out
SPEAKER_00: here will either be Jordanian
military or us. That
SPEAKER_00: makes sense. That makes sense.
You said they're faster than a torpedo?
SPEAKER_01: They're faster by being more
agile. Like, a torpedo comes up, they could
SPEAKER_01: turn. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
SPEAKER_00: More agile, that makes sense.
SPEAKER_01: Can you roll your carouse at
zero?
SPEAKER_00: I can roll my carouse at zero.
SPEAKER_00: There you go, you get a zero
carouse. I am rolling great.
SPEAKER_00: He drinks from a flask, but
offers you none. Fair enough.
SPEAKER_00: Fair enough.
SPEAKER_01: As you are in that kind of
prep, he does, though, go and get you a cup
SPEAKER_01: of coffee. And you can start
your fine Navy tradition of an unwashed
SPEAKER_01: coffee cup. Love it.
SPEAKER_03: While he goes and gets the
coffee, is the coffee on the bridge or in the
SPEAKER_03: galley?
SPEAKER_01: It is in the crew mess, which
is literally the door past the
SPEAKER_01: main control room.
SPEAKER_00: But what I'm hearing is I'm
left alone on the bridge for a period of
SPEAKER_00: time. Yes, you are. I check
the comm station.
SPEAKER_02: I'm currently sitting at it.
SPEAKER_01: She's in the radio room where
directly comms. You are able to see
SPEAKER_01: basically what has been
assigned off the radio room. What you have
SPEAKER_01: access to is sonar, weapons,
piloting, And
SPEAKER_01: controlling hatches and, like,
water pressures and things like that.
SPEAKER_03: Gotcha. There's no, like,
historical data being kept here.
SPEAKER_01: You know, like, messages that
have been approved by the radio room
SPEAKER_01: appear here. So, like, you see
the message of, hey, go pick up this crew
SPEAKER_01: that's new. You see the
message of, can Valancourt pick
SPEAKER_01: the ten people that he feels
can pilot another ship? And so he put
SPEAKER_01: his second-in-command and he
put a few other people on there to pilot
SPEAKER_01: the next ship. You have access
to that kind of data. You find out that
SPEAKER_01: Valancourt has a relationship
that is
SPEAKER_01: tumultuous on shore. He keeps
sending text messages of, I don't even
SPEAKER_01: know you're on the boat.
SPEAKER_00: You could be seeing her.
SPEAKER_01: In the storeroom are a group
of hidden energy weapons that are listed
SPEAKER_01: as welders, even though you
can tell from the
SPEAKER_01: schematics that they're
actually
SPEAKER_00: energy rifles.
SPEAKER_00: Anything about previous
salvage hauls?
SPEAKER_01: A lot of the previous salvage
hauls that they've been pulling up have
SPEAKER_01: been equipment, oxygenators,
power couplers.
SPEAKER_01: There is a few scrubbed logs
of rescue missions.
SPEAKER_01: And you see, like it says,
they went on this rescue mission. And they
SPEAKER_01: acquired the people, and then
when it talks about
SPEAKER_00: the people, that message has
been deleted. Gotcha.
SPEAKER_00: That's interesting. But I
imagine I don't have a lot of time, so I'm
SPEAKER_00: just doing a
SPEAKER_03: quick peruse and making note
of stuff and research later.
SPEAKER_01: And you make sure that, like,
if anyone comes by, it looks like you're
SPEAKER_01: practicing piloting.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah.
SPEAKER_01: Okay. So... Laura, you did so
well by the time that, like, you cover
SPEAKER_01: everything up, or Emmy comes
by and is like, oh, how are you doing? Oh,
SPEAKER_01: let me show you this part of
the radio room.
SPEAKER_02: Oh, I really appreciate it.
Like I told the captain, I'm familiar with
SPEAKER_02: spaceships and that sort, but
submarine is entirely new to
SPEAKER_02: me. I don't know. I can see
the similarities, but I also note the
SPEAKER_02: differences.
SPEAKER_01: Now, that Alan is here, Alan,
would you feel that you would be part
SPEAKER_01: of the outside crew doing,
like, welding and defense,
SPEAKER_01: or part of the flying command
crew, or some aspect of engineering?
SPEAKER_03: Probably flying command.
SPEAKER_01: Okay.
SPEAKER_03: Since I have plenty of
experience flying anything.
SPEAKER_01: Okay.
SPEAKER_03: Anything with wings.
SPEAKER_01: You're brought into the
control room and they have you do a bit of
SPEAKER_01: the piloting as he shows you
kind of the direction and we will see how
SPEAKER_01: you do on the pilot. I'm going
to roll for you. And that was a perfect
SPEAKER_01: roll. I'm never rolling for
myself again.
SPEAKER_01: You show your knowledge of
being able to control the ballast,
SPEAKER_01: you turn the sub exactly at
the angle you need to, to have a clear kind
SPEAKER_01: of area, and You pull it
within five feet of a stabilizing
SPEAKER_01: pad that the sub can lock
onto. And it basically is like almost like an
SPEAKER_01: RV plug. Like if there was
power energy coming from the station, it
SPEAKER_01: would begin to start refilling
what's there or transfer oxygen from here
SPEAKER_00: to them and the like.
SPEAKER_01: Valancourt also says, I think
it'd be a good time, though, for all of
SPEAKER_01: you to get into VAC suits to
experience it now that I've got a
SPEAKER_01: communication that your
primary VAC suit team is doing well.
SPEAKER_00: Okay.
SPEAKER_01: So, Ken, I have Cass, Varen,
and Emma. I'll roll VAC suit.
SPEAKER_02: Again, I apologize. Is that an
endurance, or is that a dexterity, or is
SPEAKER_02: that a strength?
SPEAKER_01: It is either a Dexterity or an
Education.
SPEAKER_00: Can we Buddy Check? Yeah.
SPEAKER_01: If you Buddy Check, you can
roll with a Boon. But it just takes one more
SPEAKER_01: time.
SPEAKER_02: Okay. I would like to Buddy
Check, not Buddy Check.
SPEAKER_00: Buddy Check. Always Buddy
Check. Same, same, same. All right. Boon.
SPEAKER_00: Success! And
SPEAKER_00: then, Alan, you got your roll?
Oh, wait, what? I thought I was never...
SPEAKER_00: You can roll your backsuit.
Oh, God.
SPEAKER_00: Foundry, right? You're not in
yet. I'll roll for you.
SPEAKER_03: Can you roll for me? I, like,
just walked in. No worries.
SPEAKER_01: Thank you so much. So much. He
failed. Oh, I didn't boon.
SPEAKER_03: Just clarifying, a buddy check
is for those who have already succeeded.
SPEAKER_01: So basically, buddy check is
everyone gets it with a boon, but you're
SPEAKER_01: doubling the time to put on
the suits. So, as you get more experience,
SPEAKER_01: you may not want buddy checks,
or as there's emergencies, you may not
SPEAKER_01: want buddy checks. Okay. You
put on your suit, and then
SPEAKER_01: you walk up to a guy who is
standing next to you, and he checks all your
SPEAKER_01: valves, and he checks all your
prep.
SPEAKER_00: I see.
SPEAKER_01: Okay. All of you have VAC
suits now with success.
SPEAKER_01: You go to... The airlock, it
fills with water, and as you come off, you
SPEAKER_01: see the rest of the outside
people all kind of going there. They've been
SPEAKER_01: holding onto parts of the ship
as things have been kind of moving, and
SPEAKER_01: you are at your first
location, the Hadal Research Site.
SPEAKER_01: There is aspects of Hadal that
when you are looking at it, there is
SPEAKER_01: still some energy here, but
you do see some domes have been shattered.
SPEAKER_01: You do see wreckage on the
ground.
SPEAKER_00: You do see some corpses.
SPEAKER_00: In the ship? No, at the Hidal
Research site.
SPEAKER_02: It's on the map, yeah. If you
load in, you can see the map.
SPEAKER_02: This is a different location
than the secret message I intercepted.
SPEAKER_00: I don't know.
SPEAKER_02: I don't know. It didn't come
with coordinates?
SPEAKER_00: What's your naval coordinates
knowledge?
SPEAKER_02: Super good at that.
SPEAKER_01: They said, SOS, we're at this
number. And you're like, that's a
SPEAKER_01: number. Maybe one of us who
has a...
SPEAKER_03: One second, I'm
SPEAKER_00: pulling up my...
SPEAKER_03: Would I be in the same area as
you, Zora? All you guys are in the
SPEAKER_03: same...
SPEAKER_02: Yeah, but I intercepted that
by sneaky means. It wasn't something you
SPEAKER_02: would have been able to
overhear. It was through a communication sonar
SPEAKER_02: channel. What was the skill to
figure out where that location is,
SPEAKER_02: navigation?
SPEAKER_01: No, it would actually be...
Where is it?
SPEAKER_03: Seafarer. Yeah, there's a
Seafarer skill. Which I think one of us had in
SPEAKER_03: the last game. And it was
very... I will Jack of all trades it.
SPEAKER_00: Okay. I haven't told you.
SPEAKER_01: That's just to tell you where
it is first. My bad, my bad. I apologize.
SPEAKER_00: Jumping the shark. Well, the
shark's going over you. I'm under the
SPEAKER_00: shark. You're under the shark.
SPEAKER_01: Okay. Yeah. Now, that you're
at Hadal, there's a few roles that people
SPEAKER_01: can choose to do. Recon, you
can directly see which ones may still be
SPEAKER_01: powered at a distance. You can
try to go and find out what
SPEAKER_01: work and stuff that you might
be able to pull that way. Now, you can try
SPEAKER_01: to do remote ops for Soshi and
anyone else who
SPEAKER_01: has a remote ops of a high
level and actually control the drone that is
SPEAKER_01: basically sailing around. I am
willing to hear other
SPEAKER_01: crazy ideas, like you can try
to do a communication to listen if
SPEAKER_01: anything's coming through. You
guys could try to do a lot of stuff. But
SPEAKER_01: those are the open ones. I'm
happy to hear hijinks.
SPEAKER_03: Yeah, I mean, that
communication prompt is not a bad one. If
SPEAKER_03: there was any sort of like I
have ideas for Survival and
SPEAKER_03: Velter, but my Recon is
higher.
SPEAKER_01: So, well, but they're all
going to get different things. Remember that.
SPEAKER_01: So if you roll Recon, you're
going to find the same Recon stuff. Okay.
SPEAKER_01: If anyone wants to do the
communication is with Bane, so you feel free
SPEAKER_01: to roll that.
SPEAKER_00: Sure.
SPEAKER_02: So I have a hijink that would
require or would be in that vein.
SPEAKER_02: I want to pretend that I
intercepted the message while I was outside the
SPEAKER_02: ship so I can give it to the
captains.
SPEAKER_00: Okay, I'll accept a deception.
Okay.
SPEAKER_01: You're hearing a buzz that has
some pattern to it.
SPEAKER_01: Emma, you succeed at saying,
Captain, well, actually, you're out here
SPEAKER_01: with Sabine, so you tell
Sabine, I have intercepted this communication.
SPEAKER_02: Yeah, I mean, I guess I will.
I would prefer to go right to the captain,
SPEAKER_02: but I mean, if the
communication has to be through Sabine, I can be
SPEAKER_02: like...
SPEAKER_01: He's not outside.
SPEAKER_02: Pardon me?
SPEAKER_01: The captain isn't outside the
ship. You guys are outside the ship.
SPEAKER_02: Right, and there's no way to
communicate from your device into the ship?
SPEAKER_01: So the basic ask, you have to
tell it to basically do that. It's a
SPEAKER_01: natural thing is to
communicate with the team outside of you, because
SPEAKER_01: they don't want to hear every
word of, hey, dogs that rock.
SPEAKER_02: Okay, I will tell Sabine then
that I feel that I've intercepted a
SPEAKER_02: naval message, and it involves
an SOS. Should I go and tell the captain?
SPEAKER_01: Can you transmit it up, and we
will clear ban transmit it to
SPEAKER_01: the communications on the
ship.
SPEAKER_02: Can I do that? Do I have to
roll for that? Do I have to roll comms for
SPEAKER_02: that? Because you already did
first. Boom, okay, I'm like, do I have to
SPEAKER_02: do a thing, or can I just have
it on the thing?
SPEAKER_01: Now, every player does know
where they said the statistics are. So,
SPEAKER_01: Colb, you can now roll
SPEAKER_00: your jack-of-all-traits up to
roll.
SPEAKER_00: What did you say the remote
ops would do?
SPEAKER_03: I don't think I understood
that. You're basically searching
SPEAKER_01: the site with remote
SPEAKER_03: ops. I don't know why.
SPEAKER_03: Could a sensor check be part
of it, or a computer?
SPEAKER_01: Or it would just be cons?
Probably not, but sensors, absolutely. I can
SPEAKER_01: do a sensor check. So, Josh,
as you're controlling the drone out there,
SPEAKER_01: you do find that one of the
power stations is still running, and you do
SPEAKER_01: note that there is a load. It
could be that there is another air
SPEAKER_01: filtration that it's running
to. There is some damage here. Someone
SPEAKER_01: could try to repair it to make
sure that there's no problems, but you do
SPEAKER_01: see that there is still some
activity either on computers or something
SPEAKER_01: inside the base that is taking
part of this geothermal load. Okay.
SPEAKER_00: Now, Alan, you're going to try
to just do a sensor. Yeah, do I
SPEAKER_00: roll a boon or just normal?
Just normal.
SPEAKER_00: You do notice
SPEAKER_01: that there are, of the five
domes here, three of the domes have been
SPEAKER_01: broken and two of the other
domes do have damage but are
SPEAKER_00: still holding oxygen inside of
them.
SPEAKER_00: Anyone who has not rolled have
any hijinks they'd like to try? I
SPEAKER_00: was just giving anyone else a
chance if you wanted to roll Recon to roll
SPEAKER_00: it. I could still do some
shenanigans with the drone.
SPEAKER_00: So you've gotten to where
SPEAKER_01: one of the oxygenated domes
are, and you see that the
SPEAKER_01: airlock has been blown
SPEAKER_00: away with underwater
explosives.
SPEAKER_00: Did we lose the net? No, I'm
here. I'm here. Is there anything you'd
SPEAKER_00: like to investigate or do with
that?
SPEAKER_03: Can the drone go through the
explosive,
SPEAKER_01: like, can I go deeper? So let
me kind of describe it. You can tell me
SPEAKER_01: how you want to do it. Okay.
So you had an airlock, and one of the doors
SPEAKER_01: was blown off. Yeah. So if you
go to the second door, you can get there.
SPEAKER_01: But if you open it, the water
goes in. Sure. So you could try to just
SPEAKER_01: drill it or break it with the
drone and keep on going. But then it is
SPEAKER_01: sealed. Its seal would no
longer be sealed. Right.
SPEAKER_02: Yeah. Oh, I'm not there.
SPEAKER_03: But you are on comms, right? I
mean, I can describe this to the team and
SPEAKER_03: say, we've got some explosive
damage, but there's one door
SPEAKER_03: that has compression behind
it.
SPEAKER_02: Idis would be concerned that
there are survivors of any kind.
SPEAKER_03: Ooh, can I do anything like
listen to sonar and see if I can...
SPEAKER_03: I don't know. Determine if
there's any...
SPEAKER_00: So, it's about the size of...
SPEAKER_00: It's about 40 by 40.
SPEAKER_01: So, you're not going to easily
get sound there through a
SPEAKER_01: drone. It would take people
going there and doing sensor rolls and
SPEAKER_01: actually using equipment on
the edge of it. Okay. Also, there is
SPEAKER_01: noise from the generators
nearby.
SPEAKER_03: OK. Well, like I said, I was
mostly on a recon for this.
SPEAKER_03: So I will continue to, I will
actually just say all of that to the team
SPEAKER_03: over comms. I will say, we've
got a compression area, an area withheld
SPEAKER_03: compression, but I don't want
to try
SPEAKER_03: breaching for sake of damaging
anything interior.
SPEAKER_03: Is there anything that
leadership would like to do or
SPEAKER_03: send a crew down?
SPEAKER_00: Sabine says this is
SPEAKER_01: a salvage setup. If you feel
that there's important salvage behind
SPEAKER_01: there, feel free to break the
seal. If you feel that we need to invest
SPEAKER_01: more,
SPEAKER_00: that needs to be part of your
recommendation.
SPEAKER_00: I just don't know if there's
SPEAKER_03: a protocol for sealed breach
SPEAKER_03: because I would hate to
diminish the value of the
SPEAKER_03: salvage recovery by
SPEAKER_03: introducing atmospheric
compression to the interior.
SPEAKER_01: If there are better mechanics,
maybe we can get some scrap To surround
SPEAKER_01: the hole and basically build a
faux airlock to get people
SPEAKER_00: in to see what the recovery
is.
SPEAKER_03: Do we have the equipment to
basically secure or
SPEAKER_03: weld a makeshift
SPEAKER_01: airlock, as you said? So let
me kind of describe what it would be. You
SPEAKER_01: basically, everyone who wants
to go in and explore would go up against
SPEAKER_01: the door and then outside
people would weld that shut. And then you'd
SPEAKER_01: pop the hole and only part of
the water that would come in.
SPEAKER_03: And only the water that's in
the bubble, yes, would go in. And then,
SPEAKER_03: yeah. That would have to be a
manned mission. So are there any mans that
SPEAKER_03: want to raise hands?
SPEAKER_02: I'm still concerned about
survivors being in there because this is a
SPEAKER_02: Patrick game. Well, survivors
as in like violent survivors?
SPEAKER_02: I mean, just people in
general.
SPEAKER_03: But I thought the whole point
of popping it was that even if there's
SPEAKER_03: people there, if it's only
like, let's say, you know, a room full of
SPEAKER_03: water, if it's immediately
welded behind you, even if people are not in
SPEAKER_03: VAC suits, then they'll still
be okay. I thought that was the point. Did
SPEAKER_03: I misunderstand that, Patrick?
SPEAKER_01: No.
SPEAKER_03: Yeah. And I'm also, I guess
I'm missing the metagame there. Like, if
SPEAKER_03: there's people in there and
we're worried that the people will kill us,
SPEAKER_03: we can just flood the place
with water. No, I think she means like a
SPEAKER_03: plot point of people who we'd
want to talk to, not like... Oh, yeah, no,
SPEAKER_03: this would just cause, say, 50
SPEAKER_03: gallons of water to just
splurge inside as opposed to flooding the whole
SPEAKER_03: thing. Probably like 5,000
gallons of water, but sure.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah, like 500 to 1,000, but
that's still not enough to cover a 40 by 40
SPEAKER_01: room.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah,
SPEAKER_01: so I could say that every one
that you want to have
SPEAKER_01: on the other side of the
airlock is going to be that level of success
SPEAKER_01: needed.
SPEAKER_03: Guys, I can weld it shut. I
don't mind coming in, but I think I can do
SPEAKER_03: this. Steinbach, you have some
success in welding a
SPEAKER_03: little bit ago. I suppose I
could stay out here and help you all put
SPEAKER_03: this together. Are we all who
are piloting not going inside? Is
SPEAKER_03: it like two teams?
SPEAKER_01: People choose how many they
want because that's going to matter on how
SPEAKER_01: good of a role they need.
I
SPEAKER_02: will maintain distance while
SPEAKER_02: executive being the comms
unit. I don't want to be there to complicate
SPEAKER_02: the situation because I can't
do welding. But I want to monitor the
SPEAKER_02: situation. Okay.
SPEAKER_00: State to state with no pass.
That's your executive briefing.
SPEAKER_00: Okay. Extra security,
obviously.
SPEAKER_01: Okay. So again, everyone who
wants to go, can we hear that call?
SPEAKER_03: I'll go. If we don't have
enough people to go, I will go, but I would
SPEAKER_03: think you'd rather me welding
it shut.
SPEAKER_01: Well, you could weld from the
other side.
SPEAKER_03: Okay, then I'll
SPEAKER_00: go, sure.
SPEAKER_01: I'll go. Okay, so that's
three, right?
SPEAKER_00: That's three so far.
SPEAKER_01: Okay. So Steinbach and Josh,
do you feel that you guys
SPEAKER_01: giving a boon support can get
an average three success?
SPEAKER_03: Yes, if I get a boon to
support me, I believe I could roll decently.
SPEAKER_00: Okay. So we both roll?
SPEAKER_01: No. One of you rolls, the
other gets a boon for me.
SPEAKER_03: Okay, I have a plus two, and
with my intelligence a plus four. What do
SPEAKER_03: you have, Sama? I think I'm
probably better at this. I think I'm
SPEAKER_03: effectively plus three, so
yeah, probably best then for you.
SPEAKER_00: Okay. Josh, do the roll.
SPEAKER_01: You got five. You only brought
three in, but you got five. So it's a
SPEAKER_01: very well-sealed thing.
SPEAKER_00: Thanks.
SPEAKER_01: Steinbach, as they open the
door, you do feel it kind of give like
SPEAKER_01: a shake as the pressure
changes, and you are seeing leaks that you're
SPEAKER_01: constantly working on. So can
you just
SPEAKER_01: give me a roll? I just want to
see how long it's going to hold.
SPEAKER_03: Sure. What would you like as
the roll?
SPEAKER_00: Does it get a boon? Mechanics.
You said mechanics?
SPEAKER_00: Nice. Nice.
SPEAKER_01: So there's eight turns they're
going to have before there's even any
SPEAKER_01: leakage.
SPEAKER_00: Great.
SPEAKER_01: Everyone who went in, when it
opens up, there is about
SPEAKER_01: four people in there, and
there's
SPEAKER_00: about ten people dead. So,
four people
SPEAKER_00: living and ten people dead.
These people have probably
SPEAKER_00: been in here for about,
SPEAKER_00: let's be generous, and say
three weeks. Oh my gosh.
SPEAKER_00: They are in a rough spot.
They've been basically
SPEAKER_00: converting their water vapor
back into drinkable water.
SPEAKER_00: Okay.
SPEAKER_03: I'm like, guys, we heard there
was trouble. We're here to get you out. I
SPEAKER_03: sealed the door, and I think I
did a decent job, but maybe let's get out
SPEAKER_03: of here soon, because you look
like you all could use some help. You
SPEAKER_03: have some suits? Maybe we
could help you with them?
SPEAKER_01: We don't have any suits.
SPEAKER_00: We have one here with the
attack occurring.
SPEAKER_03: Okay, I'll send a message to
outside. I'm like, we have some survivors
SPEAKER_03: here. Do we have any suits
outside that we could bring over?
SPEAKER_00: How are you going to open the
door?
SPEAKER_03: I welded it from the inside.
SPEAKER_00: I'm going to weld it back from
the outside, from the inside. Okay, so
SPEAKER_00: water will get in. That's
great. It's an emergency save. It's not a
SPEAKER_00: great save.
SPEAKER_01: They're going to break the
weld they made. They're going to bring the
SPEAKER_01: suits in, they're going to
redo the weld, and then they're going to
SPEAKER_01: reopen the thing, is I think
what he's trying to say.
SPEAKER_03: I'm open to better ideas that
sound less crazy, but I don't have a
SPEAKER_03: better idea. Is there another
SPEAKER_02: way in? There were all those
escape pod things. Can they be used as
SPEAKER_02: reconnaissance pods?
SPEAKER_00: Wow, that's a really
interesting idea. So... It's
SPEAKER_00: probably
SPEAKER_01: negative 5 to 10 degrees
Fahrenheit. So they could survive
SPEAKER_01: swimming to one of those pods.
Well, they're emaciated, I presume,
SPEAKER_01: so they'll probably need help.
Right. But okay, I think Laura's plan,
SPEAKER_01: just by the way, if I'm wrong,
tell me I'm wrong. You want to pull four
SPEAKER_01: of the pods... Yeah, that was
more or less what I had. I was hoping that
SPEAKER_01: there was some sort of, like,
airlock to it, but if there's not, then...
SPEAKER_01: The problem is you don't have
a working airlock on their side. It's been
SPEAKER_01: damaged.
SPEAKER_03: Oh, okay. And it looks better
now that we've welded it.
SPEAKER_00: Okay. Does anyone have a
better plan?
SPEAKER_00: What is the actual depth that
they're at?
SPEAKER_03: I'll look it up. Can I do a
naval tactics to understand which one has a
SPEAKER_03: better odds of survival for
them? Can I help you with it, like Boone?
SPEAKER_03: Yeah, I'll accept that. If
someone's like a naval genius,
SPEAKER_03: then they should do this
instead, by the way. I have a plus one in naval
SPEAKER_03: tactics. Yes, me too.
SPEAKER_00: I have a three. Plus five.
SPEAKER_01: Honestly, they would die if
they hadn't already been pressurized to
SPEAKER_01: these depths.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah, you said 1,500?
SPEAKER_01: Yeah.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah.
SPEAKER_01: Because they've been at 1,500
for all this time. Like, you're not going
SPEAKER_01: to drain the surface and do
the bins to kill them. Like, they can
SPEAKER_01: probably, you can probably,
with people in suits, push them in
SPEAKER_01: basically the 7 to 10 feet
that you need to to get them in the tubes.
SPEAKER_01: So, Josh, did you do your
roll?
SPEAKER_00: Yeah, I got a plus 5. Okay.
SPEAKER_01: Okay. The issue is getting
them in Vax
SPEAKER_01: suits very much implies they
still have the strength and stamina to then
SPEAKER_01: get to the ship. Laura's plan
is you guys are literally hauling tubes,
SPEAKER_01: so they don't need any energy.
Okay.
SPEAKER_01: It will be everyone who's
pulling them is going to have to do Vax suits
SPEAKER_01: of literally pushing against
the sea falling into this thing.
SPEAKER_01: Everyone who's inside, though,
can you give me an investigation? Yeah.
SPEAKER_01: I want to see all the people
who are in the HAB give me an
SPEAKER_01: investigation.
SPEAKER_03: Regular investigational?
SPEAKER_01: Yeah.
SPEAKER_03: Okay. Where is investigation?
The drone stayed outside the HAB because
SPEAKER_03: it can't...
SPEAKER_00: The drone stayed outside.
Yeah. Yeah. Lie. Did that include me?
SPEAKER_00: Everyone who wins. Okay. Nice.
SPEAKER_00: That's amazing, Varian.
SPEAKER_01: Wow. Oh. And by the way, that
was him rocking it with an untrained
SPEAKER_01: investigator. No, I saw him.
He rolled an 11. I know, but he has
SPEAKER_01: negative three on the roll.
Yeah, awesome. There was one other person
SPEAKER_01: in there, right?
SPEAKER_00: There, supposedly. I didn't
know who that person is.
SPEAKER_02: Sochi was technically there,
but she didn't take the drone in, so she's
SPEAKER_02: just outside.
SPEAKER_01: Sochi doesn't have an
investigation, she only has a recon, right?
SPEAKER_03: No, so I think Sochi is
inside, but doesn't have the drone with her, is
SPEAKER_03: that correct?
SPEAKER_01: No, no, I'm back on the ship.
Okay, who was, there were three people who
SPEAKER_01: went in. It was Peter, it was
Josh, and it was one other person.
SPEAKER_00: I guess it was Alan. It was
Casp.
SPEAKER_01: Oh, it's Cass. Okay. Can Cass
roll his investigation?
SPEAKER_00: I misunderstood when you said
it inside the ship. I thought you meant on
SPEAKER_00: our original submarine.
SPEAKER_03: Everyone is in the hat. Oh,
are you in the ship that we're in, or are
SPEAKER_03: you on the submarine? Hey,
finally a decent roll, and it's something I
SPEAKER_03: suck at.
SPEAKER_01: Okay, so I am going to give it
to Alan, just because that was the most
SPEAKER_01: amazing roll. Yay! One of the
people who
SPEAKER_01: is all emaciated,
SPEAKER_00: he looks exactly like the
politician.
SPEAKER_00: Like emaciated? What does that
mean?
SPEAKER_01: He's been without water for a
week. No, food without. Food without a
SPEAKER_00: week. And he looks like the
politician?
SPEAKER_02: They're super skinny.
SPEAKER_01: He looks very much like the
leader of genetic research that you were all
SPEAKER_01: in the room that you saw blown
to pieces.
SPEAKER_00: Exactly like him? I don't know
how I can phrase
SPEAKER_00: exactly.
SPEAKER_01: He looks like him. If one of
them is living the life of Riley and then
SPEAKER_01: the other just had a very
harrowing experience, Uh, yeah.
SPEAKER_01: So, I just want you to note
that while you guys are doing that.
SPEAKER_01: Obviously, you're not going to
be, like, stopping and interrogating the
SPEAKER_01: dude while he's, like, barely
able to lift his hand.
SPEAKER_03: I mean, this might be the best
time.
SPEAKER_00: You're like, I promise you
good life.
SPEAKER_00: You're definitely one of the
ones you want to do.
SPEAKER_01: Okay. So, everyone gets the
tubes over here.
SPEAKER_01: Steinbach, can you give me
another machinist roll? Because you're trying
SPEAKER_01: to get the tubes as soon as
possible and basically have them float
SPEAKER_01: forward as the break occurs.
Nice, Steinbach. Perfect. There we go.
SPEAKER_01: Okay. I'm actually going to
say with that roll, you get everyone in the
SPEAKER_01: tube. Because I was going to
make it that you had to get four successes
SPEAKER_01: across both sides, and you
just got four successes. So you get the four
SPEAKER_01: people in the tube, all of you
gradually lug them back.
SPEAKER_01: Other things that are found,
you guys find some power generators, you
SPEAKER_01: find a few computer things,
you find
SPEAKER_01: few data cubes, and you do
find a
SPEAKER_00: computer chip that is
seafaring land.
SPEAKER_00: So anyone who has a computer
chip can try to put it in for their seat
SPEAKER_00: bearing.
Cool.
SPEAKER_03: I definitely wanted to stop
and get chips beforehand, but we are kind of
SPEAKER_03: wounded criminals,
unfortunately.
SPEAKER_01: You're like, hey, no one needs
that. Let me shove that in right now.
SPEAKER_01: Okay.
SPEAKER_02: We've got a helmet on, so we
can't quite do that.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah, so you guys all get back
on the sub. And let's go back to...
SPEAKER_03: So while we're waiting, do we
have time to talk with them and ask them
SPEAKER_03: what happened, or not really?
SPEAKER_01: Well, no, because they're in
the pods, and you guys are
SPEAKER_00: not in pods.
SPEAKER_03: No, I mean while we were
waiting for the pods to get there.
SPEAKER_00: They're not feeling so great.
Okay, so fine.
SPEAKER_03: Kiernan's going to start going
through the process of first aid as best
SPEAKER_03: he can on some of these
people.
SPEAKER_01: That would be perfect. Can you
give me the first aid, and I do have a
SPEAKER_01: question. Are you trying to
focus on anyone in particular, or are you
SPEAKER_01: trying to make sure all of
them live?
SPEAKER_03: Kiernan hasn't recognized any,
right? There is a role necessary to
SPEAKER_03: recognize some familiarity
with these people.
SPEAKER_01: But is it a triage you're
trying to keep everyone alive, or are you just
SPEAKER_01: trying to make sure some
people live?
SPEAKER_03: It's triage. He's trying to
keep as many people alive as he can.
SPEAKER_01: Okay, roll with a...
SPEAKER_03: Unless I'm doing too much, I
can assist with that. I have a pretty good
SPEAKER_03: medic check.
SPEAKER_01: Okay, I'll let you roll it
natural then.
SPEAKER_03: Awesome. Me? He nods his head
into you as you come
SPEAKER_03: in for assistance.
SPEAKER_00: Ugh. Well, I don't know why...
SPEAKER_01: So, Alan, two people almost
never do a roll. Oh, I didn't
SPEAKER_03: know that. I'm so sorry.
SPEAKER_01: No worries.
SPEAKER_03: It's funny because he said, I
would like to help. And at first you said
SPEAKER_03: he should be on the boon, and
then you're like, okay, then you said,
SPEAKER_03: never mind.
SPEAKER_01: And that made it a normal.
SPEAKER_03: Okay. Oh, okay. So I should
never roll then.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah, it's fine. So now, I
would like, who feels lucky tonight?
SPEAKER_00: I feel lucky.
SPEAKER_01: Okay, I would like you to pick
a number of 1 through 4. The number you
SPEAKER_01: pick is the guy who looks like
the person who was there.
SPEAKER_01: I'm going to roll a 1d4, okay?
And we're going to see if that's the one
SPEAKER_01: who lived.
SPEAKER_00: Oh, so, oh, three died. The
reason we're dying? He rolled a neg 3.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah. Wow. Dice gods
SPEAKER_00: are cruel. Okay, two. Two,
okay.
SPEAKER_00: Too late! Cha-ching, folks.
That is a
SPEAKER_00: really lucky moment. Dice gods
are cruel
SPEAKER_00: things.
SPEAKER_03: Is that like me coming over to
help with the medic and I'm like, hey,
SPEAKER_03: isn't there like a hole here
in his chest? Maybe she plugged that thing
SPEAKER_03: right there.
SPEAKER_01: And you're like, maybe this
guy needs us.
SPEAKER_03: I mean, what it comes down to,
like, realistically, is
SPEAKER_03: the best he can do for some of
these people is give them thermal
SPEAKER_03: blankets, give them little
nibblings of food,
SPEAKER_03: and try and get your bodies
to, like, thermoregulate. And it literally
SPEAKER_03: just comes down to, we need to
give them time and see how they react.
SPEAKER_01: And then The biggest issue is,
by the way, they were pressurized under
SPEAKER_01: there, and you're pressurized
at a different pressure.
SPEAKER_03: Exactly. It's just kind of
seeing how the goldfish acclimate to the new
SPEAKER_03: pond. We just see who lives
and who dies.
SPEAKER_01: In a matter of an hour, all of
them are dead but one.
SPEAKER_01: It is the one, though, that
Alan has realized looks like the other
SPEAKER_01: person. Now, I would say
everyone who's been around him and touching him
SPEAKER_01: has kind of realized it now,
too. I'm sorry, what? Everyone's kind of
SPEAKER_01: picked it up on now. He's the
last living guy. You're all looking at him
SPEAKER_01: a lot. Okay.
SPEAKER_00: I mean, maybe I'll say into
the thing. Hey, remember my friend John?
SPEAKER_03: What's the guy's name again?
Actually, I'll say his name.
SPEAKER_02: I gotta look at my notes.
SPEAKER_03: It's the author of the... Oh,
I
SPEAKER_03: might have the wrong guy
thought of. Patrick, what's
SPEAKER_02: the last name? Oh, I just
wrote it as the guy who was murdered.
SPEAKER_01: It is... Mercer is his last
name, so I'm right now trying to guess his
SPEAKER_00: first name.
SPEAKER_01: It's interesting, you know,
this guy reminds me of a friend of mine. I'm
SPEAKER_01: sorry, what was it? A-L-A-I-N.
Align.
SPEAKER_03: I'm like, this guy reminds me
a lot of a friend of mine. A friend of
SPEAKER_03: mine who has passed on,
unfortunately, Mercer. Like, the spitting image
SPEAKER_03: of him. Like, they could be
twins or something. Do I say something? Do
SPEAKER_03: you say this out loud? I say
this, like, over the mic so that the rest
SPEAKER_03: of the team can hear.
SPEAKER_01: I would also say that this guy
is currently unconscious but stable.
SPEAKER_03: He's asleep, but, you know,
you might want to come and see my good
SPEAKER_03: friend, guys, if you can get
off from your duty stations. Maybe we can
SPEAKER_03: poke him with poking stick. He
looks like he should not be
SPEAKER_03: poked. He probably shouldn't
poke friends.
SPEAKER_02: He didn't do anything to us.
He's the one who got hurt, so we don't need
SPEAKER_02: to torture his twin brother.
SPEAKER_03: Well, we don't know that. We
don't know that yet. But we shouldn't start
SPEAKER_03: with that, perhaps. Please
don't let friends vote unconsciously. I'm
SPEAKER_03: joking. I'm joking. I didn't
say that.
SPEAKER_02: I'm just saying that the guy
who got murdered, I don't think, wanted to
SPEAKER_02: get murdered.
SPEAKER_03: You're not a victim blamer?
Like, if you got murdered, you probably
SPEAKER_03: deserved it? No. Liberals.
SPEAKER_02: It's true. My bleeding heart
is right on my sleeve.
SPEAKER_03: He was in the wrong part of
the government building.
SPEAKER_02: What was he wearing?
SPEAKER_03: Yeah, yeah. He was asking for
a bit of movement. Yeah, yeah. It's what
SPEAKER_03: he was wearing. Listen, by
definition, anyone who gets murdered doesn't
SPEAKER_03: want to die. Otherwise, it's a
sacrifice.
SPEAKER_00: We're all terrible people.
SPEAKER_03: In a private channel to
Caspian,
SPEAKER_03: he's just going to say in the
private channel, hey, so it looks like we
SPEAKER_03: found some evidence. Yes,
SPEAKER_03: it does appear to be that way.
And we need to log this, and then, you
SPEAKER_03: know, it'll be some days
before we can feed this information.
SPEAKER_02: But keep cool, man. Keep cool.
SPEAKER_03: What you need to do is stop
giving him grace and start giving him food.
SPEAKER_03: Let us let him nap first.
Look, he looks so peaceful.
SPEAKER_02: It was more that he probably
needs an IV. I don't think he can eat a
SPEAKER_02: cube without vomiting
everywhere.
SPEAKER_03: Oh, I've been trying to find
them for some time. They're
SPEAKER_03: quite swollen.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah, IV in a decompression
chamber, I would say.
SPEAKER_00: Yep. And maybe a feeding tube?
SPEAKER_03: If it stays in a coma long
enough?
SPEAKER_00: He's not in a
SPEAKER_03: coma, he's just sleeping. I'm
assuming he's in a coma until he wakes up.
SPEAKER_03: Isn't that what being in a
coma is? Being asleep until you wake up and
SPEAKER_03: then you're no longer in a
coma? I guess we each go into a coma every
SPEAKER_03: night. This is my medical
opinion. So you guys put him in the sick bag
SPEAKER_03: and you guys are having at
least someone with medicine with him.
SPEAKER_03: Valancourt says he's wearing a
Jardinian navel uniform.
SPEAKER_01: We have to decide if he can
survive or take him
SPEAKER_00: to the undersea base.
SPEAKER_02: The one in the center, right?
SPEAKER_03: Well, I think he would
probably do best if he came back with us to the
SPEAKER_03: company. He could get the best
care there, I think.
SPEAKER_01: He's Jordanian Navy. We have
no right to take him.
SPEAKER_00: We're not taking him. We're
bringing him back as a rescue.
SPEAKER_00: Josh, are you just your
character talking that suspiciously? Or like...
SPEAKER_00: I just want to chat. I don't
want to...
SPEAKER_00: I guess I didn't know it's
suspicious.
SPEAKER_01: Well, he's directly saying
that we could be like an hour away from an
SPEAKER_01: undersea base, or we can take
him to naval medical staff, and you're
SPEAKER_01: like, you know, how about we
like, kidnap him?
SPEAKER_03: Okay, I'm going to shut up
then if I'm saying something.
SPEAKER_01: You can phrase it in another
way. That's why I don't want to have these
SPEAKER_01: words locked down.
SPEAKER_03: I thought that how far away
are we from where we took off? Like if
SPEAKER_03: you're saying a naval base is
an hour, how far away is it?
SPEAKER_01: To get back to the main
location, you're one hour away
SPEAKER_00: under sea base.
SPEAKER_00: You know what? I'm not the
social guy.
SPEAKER_03: I'm going to take a back seat.
If someone else wants to say something,
SPEAKER_03: they can say something. So,
just so that I have
SPEAKER_03: this right, we found him, we
found four people, and now we're deciding
SPEAKER_03: what we're doing with them?
SPEAKER_00: Well, three of them die. Three
of them die. Also, we're not the captain.
SPEAKER_01: Right, but he's waiting for
medical advice, and some of you guys seem to
SPEAKER_01: be medically taking care of
him.
SPEAKER_03: So then medically, I would
say, well, really what I think is that we
SPEAKER_03: should stay at this pressure
level for as long as possible so his
SPEAKER_03: oxygen level can equalize. And
on our way back, I
SPEAKER_03: think that's the best way for
him to stabilize.
SPEAKER_01: Okay, so that answer is that
we take him to the understate base, which
SPEAKER_01: is that pressure level.
SPEAKER_03: Well, that's going to be at a
slightly different pressure than we are
SPEAKER_03: right now. I don't think he
can afford that. He's in a shaky situation.
SPEAKER_01: But if we take him to the
naval base, he has to decompress faster.
SPEAKER_03: Yeah, but we don't want him to
decompress faster. We want him to be
SPEAKER_03: slowly. That's how you get the
bubbles. Wait, what is it called? It's
SPEAKER_03: called the...
SPEAKER_01: Yeah, that's how you get the
bends. Okay, so just so I'm trying to
SPEAKER_01: understand the clarity. One
is, because nine hours back to the
SPEAKER_01: naval base is not going to be
enough for a decompression. So we'd have
SPEAKER_01: to basically wait a week in
front of the naval base, gradually
SPEAKER_01: decompressing.
SPEAKER_03: Wait, wait. So he's saying,
when you say the Gardenian Navy, correct?
SPEAKER_01: Yes. Like, I will push
everyone to undersea, so we're all talking on the
SPEAKER_01: same. Is everyone on undersea?
SPEAKER_03: If I understand it correctly,
an hour away, at the same death we're at,
SPEAKER_03: there is a Navy base, and he
has a Navy uniform. And they would keep him
SPEAKER_03: there until it's safe.
SPEAKER_01: Undersea Base Allion is
Transtar.
SPEAKER_03: Oh, okay.
SPEAKER_01: But there's no medical support
there.
SPEAKER_03: Oh, as long as it's Transtar
Base, right? Like, that's a key part of
SPEAKER_03: that piece, yeah. Yeah.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah. The Jordanian Base on
the coast is full-on naval military. Okay.
SPEAKER_03: If you need medical help at
the Transstar base, why does it sound crazy
SPEAKER_03: if I say we go to the
Transstar base?
SPEAKER_01: You didn't say the Transstar
base. He asked twice if you want the
SPEAKER_01: undersea base, and you said
no. You said you wanted to Transstar, which
SPEAKER_01: sounds like it's the one on
the coast. That's what I'm trying to just
SPEAKER_01: get cleared. So you're saying
you do want the base that's an hour away.
SPEAKER_01: That's the Transstar base?
There are Transstar and there are military
SPEAKER_01: people there, but Transstar
owns it.
SPEAKER_03: Yeah, we want to go to the
TransDar, please.
SPEAKER_01: So let's call it Undersea Base
Allion, as is listed on the map.
SPEAKER_03: Okay.
SPEAKER_00: I mean, does anyone... I kind
of look around, like...
SPEAKER_00: Does anyone have a idea? No.
SPEAKER_00: No, we definitely want to be a
proper PECON champion.
SPEAKER_00: If everyone's of a...
SPEAKER_02: Yeah, I'm just saying, again,
the military base is nine hours away, and
SPEAKER_02: then this one is one hour
away.
SPEAKER_03: We do the one hour.
SPEAKER_02: Yeah, I'm very confused why
you'd want to kill him.
SPEAKER_03: What? No, it's not about the
time, it's about the control, right? Like,
SPEAKER_03: if we put him in our company,
we can have access to him. Even if it was
SPEAKER_03: reversed, if we would put him
in a military base, then we maybe never
SPEAKER_03: see him again. Yeah, he might
go get offed, since they did try to
SPEAKER_03: pretend off
SPEAKER_00: him, at least. Okay.
SPEAKER_01: So, you guys start moving
towards undersea base Elyon at full speed that
SPEAKER_01: you can. You arrive in an
hour, and
SPEAKER_01: the communication of...
SPEAKER_01: Remy Buchchamp, he basically
sends a message that we have a rescued
SPEAKER_01: person. The rest of the crew
died from the attack that happened a
SPEAKER_01: few weeks ago, and
SPEAKER_01: we are needing medical
assistance right away. He is Sardinian Navy. We
SPEAKER_01: don't have an identification,
but he's in a naval uniform. As you
SPEAKER_01: guys pull up, There is a full
crisis team there
SPEAKER_01: that is there with the body.
They start working on it right there as
SPEAKER_01: they're taking him to a med
bay. You guys are happy to follow.
SPEAKER_01: And they start doing
SPEAKER_00: work on him. And let's see how
quickly they recover.
SPEAKER_00: Is there anything we can do to
aid their medic roles?
SPEAKER_01: They're basically all Medic 4,
Intelligence Plus 3s. Okay. They're a
SPEAKER_01: full team. They do incredibly
well. You guys see some color in him. They
SPEAKER_01: basically shoot him with
SPEAKER_01: nanites that are going to
start trying to repair the damage on his
SPEAKER_01: body and be able to Clean up
the bends issue by actually going through
SPEAKER_01: his veins
SPEAKER_00: and gradually equalizing the
pressures.
SPEAKER_00: You see him actually awake as
some of this is occurring. Ten that
SPEAKER_00: they fully healed him, they
got him at an eight.
SPEAKER_01: So, you see him taken to the
medical area, they have him, like, under an
SPEAKER_01: observation area, but he's not
under, like, armed guard or anything.
SPEAKER_02: Right, but did we really all
go, like, is there really, like, eight of
SPEAKER_02: us hovering around this guy
and a robot?
SPEAKER_01: I imagine that it's much more
like, hey, you know, we rescued this guy.
SPEAKER_01: It's like when you watch
Abyss. Like everyone is helping out the person
SPEAKER_01: who's been swimming underwater
without a suit kind of thing. This base,
SPEAKER_01: by the way, has a very strong
SPEAKER_00: vibe like the undersea mining
platform from Abyss. Okay.
SPEAKER_00: But there is a bar and there's
probably
SPEAKER_01: 60 to 100 personnel on this
place. The most
SPEAKER_01: noteworthy thing is they have
a full-size airlock to actually bring
SPEAKER_01: ships in it. So if
SPEAKER_01: there is repairs that need to
be done that the ship's not going to be
SPEAKER_01: able to make the nine hours
back to the coast, they can do work on it.
SPEAKER_00: Sort of a mini dry dock
almost.
SPEAKER_02: Exactly. Can they look into
the little ship that's on our ship that's
SPEAKER_02: all bustinated?
SPEAKER_01: You do see that there's a lot
of replacement ships of that type around
SPEAKER_01: here. But they are not They're
SPEAKER_01: not going on your ship and
investigating that. Valancourt is filling out
SPEAKER_01: the paperwork of what occurred
and is trying to kind of
SPEAKER_01: basically say they have this
and Sabine is
SPEAKER_01: also taking all the bodies and
she's prepping them for
SPEAKER_01: transport to the military to
tell their families that these people He
SPEAKER_01: basically died under the ocean
and what was happening in the
SPEAKER_01: line. As things were kind of
basically progressing, Valancourt
SPEAKER_01: gradually calls you guys back
on the comms and says, while we are going
SPEAKER_01: to be here for a day,
SPEAKER_00: I would like to speak to
everyone in the cruise mess.
SPEAKER_00: Okay. And everyone... Yeah, we
go.
SPEAKER_01: It's like I have a lot of
things to say. The first thing is I think I'm
SPEAKER_01: very honored that all of you
risked what was necessary
SPEAKER_01: to attempt to rescue people
that were trapped underwater. There's a lot
SPEAKER_01: of people their first few days
under the sea would be paralyzed by the
SPEAKER_01: idea of attempting to
jury-rig, airlocks, be able
SPEAKER_01: to give them the paths The
fact that you are running straight in and
SPEAKER_01: being a crew to help all of
those that may be hurt is
SPEAKER_00: true honor for your work here.
The
SPEAKER_00: thing I would like to bring
up, though, is the location we went to was
SPEAKER_00: not a Jordanian military base.
SPEAKER_00: It was a transtar research
facility. And
SPEAKER_00: the fact that you were in a
room full of military Jordanian Navy makes
SPEAKER_00: me wonder why they were in
there alone to even be captured.
SPEAKER_00: Well, do we, is it
SPEAKER_03: possible that all of the
trans-star personnel on that base had perished,
SPEAKER_03: and they just, we just
happened to have the military people left alive
SPEAKER_00: after everyone else died?
SPEAKER_01: I can't imagine a, and by the
way, all ten people you saw in
SPEAKER_01: there, even the dead ones,
were in Jordanian military uniforms.
SPEAKER_00: Okay.
SPEAKER_01: I can't imagine a full naval
group there getting trapped.
SPEAKER_01: Even if they do rewrite this
as there was a naval team attempting to
SPEAKER_01: rescue a transtar scientist
and they got trapped on their own,
SPEAKER_00: where was the ship that got
them there? These people were there.
SPEAKER_00: And I can't imagine they were
there for a positive transtar response.
SPEAKER_02: Well, we did intercept that
message that was only to the military as it
SPEAKER_02: was. So there's some
SPEAKER_02: veracity to your statement of
why were they there in the first place
SPEAKER_02: kind of thing. If you...
SPEAKER_00: Hold on. I want to actually
look at my skill. What is my diplomacy
SPEAKER_00: actually at?
SPEAKER_02: My deception is actually two,
and my diplomat. Oh, my diplomat's
SPEAKER_02: actually negative three. I
only have deception. Good job. I can only
SPEAKER_02: lie. I can't be nice.
SPEAKER_03: Do we have any diplomats among
us? I don't even know. I think I have a
SPEAKER_03: point
SPEAKER_00: in it.
SPEAKER_02: You're, like, very broadly
spaced.
SPEAKER_00: I have two. I have two points
in diplomacy. I am not diplomatic
SPEAKER_00: at all.
SPEAKER_02: What I was going to say was
that it may be advantageous to us to find
SPEAKER_02: out what he was doing there,
especially since he is currently in a
SPEAKER_02: Transgard location. We can
push that out as far as we can.
SPEAKER_00: We can even poke him. Let's
not poke. Let's
SPEAKER_00: not poke anyone. I know it's
beyond your scope.
SPEAKER_01: Being naval officers, but if
you are better at gathering that
SPEAKER_01: information before we are
asked to leave him here, I might
SPEAKER_00: be able to delay our ship
leaving in two days. I'm
SPEAKER_00: sure I can figure out a way by
not poking him.
SPEAKER_01: It also might be helpful as he
looks at Steinbach
SPEAKER_01: And Josh,
SPEAKER_00: maybe you might be able to
create an accident with
SPEAKER_00: your machine work to distract
SPEAKER_01: them while other members
didn't get information.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah, that sounds doable. I
think we can set up the distraction easily
SPEAKER_00: enough. Let's not have any
corpses, please.
SPEAKER_00: What? I would never. We're in
the life-saving business.
SPEAKER_03: We're the good guys.
SPEAKER_00: Let's go blow shit up.
SPEAKER_03: Except when we kill lost three
out of four. You
SPEAKER_03: know, when it comes to
pressurized zombies, one out of four is great
SPEAKER_03: odds. I'm great. Yes.
SPEAKER_01: Serena made a point to take
hair samples of all the dead people, so...
SPEAKER_01: When we get back to Transtar,
we can genetically check to see who they
SPEAKER_01: are.
SPEAKER_02: Can we do that to the guy? Has
that not already been done? She's
SPEAKER_01: like, I took hair from the
dead. I wasn't going to take it from a living
SPEAKER_01: guy.
SPEAKER_02: Well, I mean, but has the
hospital done that yet since he doesn't have
SPEAKER_02: any identification on him or
on the uniform?
SPEAKER_01: I don't know, but the
communications are going to be massively delayed
SPEAKER_01: down there.
SPEAKER_00: So if you're worried about his
identity, maybe your accident should be
SPEAKER_00: the communicators.
SPEAKER_01: Annette, you also can walk
outside the base and basically
SPEAKER_01: stay outside the guy's room
and investigate who comes in and who comes
SPEAKER_01: out because no one's going to
expect someone to be able to literally be
SPEAKER_01: outside for hours on end.
SPEAKER_03: Yep. That sounds great. Take
my fully charged
SPEAKER_03: guard watch. Yep.
SPEAKER_00: Can you give me a Recon Roll?
Would you have a ? Yeah.
SPEAKER_00: Pass. Yep.
SPEAKER_01: You see about what would
normally be like 11 to
SPEAKER_01: 1 at night. A SolSec operative
goes in there.
SPEAKER_01: He does some scanning on the
guy who is quote-unquote asleep.
SPEAKER_01: And he takes his hand and he
makes a hand scan of it. Makes a hand do
SPEAKER_01: what? Hand scan, that's me.
Oh, OK, scan.
SPEAKER_02: I heard hand scan, and I'm
like, he just like picked the guy up.
SPEAKER_01: This guy is SolSec. He is in a
SPEAKER_01: SolSec-labeled environment.
SPEAKER_03: Yeah, I send a security notice
report to the rest of the team just
SPEAKER_03: because that's my job.
SPEAKER_00: Is anyone going to try to stop
the SoulSec agent?
SPEAKER_02: I don't know if I can stop him
from where I am, but as a former SoulSec
SPEAKER_02: person myself, can I know what
he's doing? Laura thinks she has an idea,
SPEAKER_02: but I'd like to confirm it
through my character.
SPEAKER_00: What sciences do you have? Or
medicine? What sciences do I have?
SPEAKER_02: I have psychology at one, and
I have everything else at zero. And then
SPEAKER_02: what was the other thing? I
apologize. Medicine? I have medic at one.
SPEAKER_02: Yeah, I have medic at one.
Okay.
SPEAKER_00: Education or intellect?
Educate.
Okay.
SPEAKER_00: Wow. One of the things that
Simple Psych does...
SPEAKER_01: When people look similar, they
basically need to prove that they are
SPEAKER_01: genetically identical because
you could do a genetic change of just
SPEAKER_01: changing your face and your
bone structure, but does that actually
SPEAKER_01: change every part of your
fingerprint? Does that change every part of
SPEAKER_01: your internal muscle growth?
What the scanners actually do also
SPEAKER_01: They scan the bone structure
in your hand to see how quickly the bones
SPEAKER_01: grew.
SPEAKER_02: Wow, that's a whole thing.
SPEAKER_00: Because it instantly tells you
how old the person is.
SPEAKER_02: Right, right, yeah. Well, if
they're a clone in
SPEAKER_02: some way, they would have been
advanced enough to look the same. I guess
SPEAKER_02: you can still look at the
calcium deposits, though.
SPEAKER_01: Right, exactly. The thing is,
an advanced clone is not doing layer after
SPEAKER_01: layer after layer. It's
building your own.
SPEAKER_02: Yeah, I thought of that after
I said it.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah.
SPEAKER_02: Okay. If I can hold on just a
minute longer to my
SPEAKER_02: turn. I'm going to presume
that that information is being transmitted to
SPEAKER_02: a database somewhere in some
capacity. Is that a stress?
SPEAKER_01: In the database they'd be set
up to.
SPEAKER_02: Pardon me?
SPEAKER_01: You know exactly what database
it's likely set up to.
SPEAKER_02: Can I try to Haxor into that
so I can see the information for myself?
SPEAKER_01: What? One in the guy's head
like yours.
SPEAKER_02: Oh, yeah, I got one in my
head.
SPEAKER_01: So he has one in his head.
SPEAKER_02: I always forget I have one in
my head, so he's got one in his head, too.
SPEAKER_02: I cannot Hax's head.
SPEAKER_01: Well, you can hack it off.
SPEAKER_02: I'm not. We're not poking
anyone, we're not hacking anyone's head up,
SPEAKER_02: we're just, we're gonna be
cool, guys. Cool, cool, cool, cool, cool. No
SPEAKER_02: doubt, no doubt.
SPEAKER_01: I'm taking that off the table,
it's just really down the list. I noticed
SPEAKER_01: you're against poking and
killing
SPEAKER_03: and murdering for some reason.
SPEAKER_01: Machinery roll, I mean, yeah,
the machining roll. Me?
SPEAKER_00: Steinbach.
Oh.
SPEAKER_00: Sorry, I didn't realize you
were talking to me on that.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah.
SPEAKER_00: You said mechanic roll?
SPEAKER_01: Yeah, Mechanic at a boom. You
did a great roll. Don't worry. You did a
SPEAKER_01: great roll. Okay, so you, with
Josh,
SPEAKER_01: basically go and you flood
concentrated salt water into the
SPEAKER_01: batteries for the
communication and basically make a minor leak they're
SPEAKER_01: going to have to fix in about
an hour. Yeah.
SPEAKER_03: My... Fair enough. I'll go
with that. I will say my thought was if we
SPEAKER_03: could sabotage the
communication
SPEAKER_02: gear in a way that they might
come to us and say, oh, well, with your
SPEAKER_02: sub, we can send messages back
to the mainland via your sub's
SPEAKER_02: communication gear while
you're parked here.
SPEAKER_03: That way we maybe then had to
tap into their communication channel.
SPEAKER_01: But the saltwater trap makes
it nice and easy. Right. The thing is
SPEAKER_01: they're not going to... You
can't relay anything out right now unless
SPEAKER_01: there's an emergency, like an
actual collapse of the base.
SPEAKER_00: Right.
SPEAKER_01: But you do stop them from
sending random stuff or having soul sex on
SPEAKER_01: their messages on the
download.
SPEAKER_00: That makes sense.
SPEAKER_01: Does anyone else have any
hygiene they want to do on the base? I would
SPEAKER_01: like to go back to if anyone
wants to actually physically intercept him,
SPEAKER_01: or at least try to
SPEAKER_00: talk to him. You want to
intercept the SolSec agent? Yeah.
SPEAKER_01: Does anyone give a pro or con
against that?
SPEAKER_03: Yeah, I just want to follow in
that same endeavor. Security ping
SPEAKER_03: has gone off, and he wants to
resolve the ping. So, I don't think I'm
SPEAKER_03: asking my opinion, but I'm not
super into this when we're in an enclosed
SPEAKER_03: space that we cannot escape
tangling with SoulSec, which is like a super
SPEAKER_03: powerful, like one of the most
powerful agencies in the world that we're
SPEAKER_03: in. So, if someone would ask
my opinion, I'd be like, how is this going
SPEAKER_03: to work?
SPEAKER_00: What's our endgame?
SPEAKER_03: I just want to talk to the
guy.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah, I am.
SPEAKER_03: I'm not talking about
kidnapping or beating him. Yeah, I'd like to find
SPEAKER_03: out if his feet's connected
to, uh, what's his face that we fed
SPEAKER_03: information to. So, like,
yeah, I support you in this
SPEAKER_03: endeavor. Yeah, uh,
unfortunately, uh, Kiernan
SPEAKER_03: is not really, he's just going
to confront the guy.
SPEAKER_00: Uh, yeah. Wait, you're going
to go confront the guy?
SPEAKER_03: No, he's backing up the
questions.
SPEAKER_03: I'm just saying that he's
just... There is backup in Russell. Are you
SPEAKER_03: all not confronting him?
Because I thought that's what you said you were
SPEAKER_03: going to do. I misunderstood.
That is what they said they were going to
SPEAKER_03: do. Intercept. Go talk to him.
Talking to someone is not confronting
SPEAKER_03: someone. There is a
difference. Sure.
SPEAKER_00: We are going.
SPEAKER_03: We are intercepting.
SPEAKER_00: Damien and Peter are going to
go intercepting. Okay.
SPEAKER_00: So he's walking down
SPEAKER_01: a corridor, and I would say
because Damien's a monkey, he comes
SPEAKER_00: from behind, and Peter comes
from the front.
SPEAKER_00: Sounds good to me. What did
you guys say? So we noticed...
SPEAKER_00: And we're not going to spread
SPEAKER_03: this around or anything, but
we noticed you were in a room taking a scan
SPEAKER_03: of a man who happens to look
exactly like an assassinated
SPEAKER_03: minister that you guys are
being partially blamed for. Now,
SPEAKER_03: we know what happened there,
but no one really believes us.
SPEAKER_03: But we believe you want to get
to the truth. So if you just want to
SPEAKER_03: share some information a bit
later or
SPEAKER_00: have a conversation about it,
we're open to that.
SPEAKER_00: Okay.
SPEAKER_01: I need you, Damien, because
you were the talker, right?
SPEAKER_00: Yeah. Yeah, I need you to roll
a athletics plus dexterity.
SPEAKER_00: Okay.
SPEAKER_00: Okay. I need you to roll it
again because both of
SPEAKER_00: us got the exact same number.
SPEAKER_00: He puts a gun to your head
before you even notice it. He basically pulls
SPEAKER_00: it out and shoves it up
against your head.
SPEAKER_01: He turns you around, and he's
now basically behind you with the gun to
SPEAKER_01: you as he now notices that
there's all these other people around him.
SPEAKER_00: You were enemies of the state,
and you dare come to me in any aspect of
SPEAKER_00: communication? Well, you see,
If we were enemies of the state,
SPEAKER_03: would that be a bright idea
for us? If we were looking for the downfall
SPEAKER_03: of anything to do with the
Somali Empire,
SPEAKER_01: wouldn't we be reaching out to
you? That would be kind of crazy now. You
SPEAKER_01: have a gun to your head,
you're a monkey, and this is a
SPEAKER_01: racist, that's a lot of
slavery. Yeah, I know.
SPEAKER_01: So... I would like an
intelligence roll. If you win the intelligence
SPEAKER_01: roll, you go on your bit.
SPEAKER_00: But most people are sick when
there's a gun to their head. I understand.
SPEAKER_00: You're quiet. Yeah. You're not
shaking in your boots, but you're quiet.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah. Are you attempting to
SPEAKER_00: interfere with SoulSec
activities? No, in this particular case, we would
SPEAKER_00: like to help. I'm
SPEAKER_00: not asking for your help. I
don't want associations with criminals.
SPEAKER_01: And whether or not the person
that you were involved in the
SPEAKER_01: assassination to has a
duplicate or the duplicate was
SPEAKER_01: killed is part of SolSec
investigation. You are currently a transtar
SPEAKER_01: employee on a transtar base,
and that is why I'm not
SPEAKER_00: putting a bullet through your
monkey face.
SPEAKER_00: But even if I did, what would
I get? A slap on the wrist as they throw
SPEAKER_00: you out for the orca.
SPEAKER_03: He pushes you to your knees,
and then he lets you go and walks away. I
SPEAKER_03: didn't hear all that.
SPEAKER_01: Emma's like, that's the kind
of agent I was.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah, the thing is, again... I
get it. I get it.
SPEAKER_01: Surrounding him is not going
to adhere him to communications.
SPEAKER_00: And by the way, Laura, you are
on mute.
SPEAKER_02: Oh, man, you didn't hear my
great story about, I was like, not story,
SPEAKER_02: but you were like, that's the
kind of agent Laura was. And I'm like,
SPEAKER_02: there was a reason I was
staying quiet through the whole thing.
SPEAKER_03: I was reading your lips. Do
you want me to tell everybody what you said?
SPEAKER_03: That
SPEAKER_02: is what I said.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah. So the rest of you are
like, hmm, maybe being up front with a
SPEAKER_01: soul set guy while we're 2,000
meters underwater. Maybe we should be a
SPEAKER_01: little bit calmer with that.
He could probably get us delayed, or put in
SPEAKER_01: a brig, or fed to the orca.
SPEAKER_03: Yeah, that approach wasn't the
approach I would have taken, but I do
SPEAKER_03: appreciate the effort.
SPEAKER_00: Good, Tim.
SPEAKER_01: So... We are at 1130. If
anyone has any things that they would like to
SPEAKER_01: get wrapped up, I'm happy to
do it. And I'm happy to basically, you guys
SPEAKER_01: are locking out communication
and you're going to obviously try to be
SPEAKER_01: more friendly with the SoulSec
person in another time period. We are?
SPEAKER_01: I imagine. Okay. I want him to
send negative data about you. Well, not
SPEAKER_01: less friendly.
SPEAKER_03: Yeah, we can find someone else
who can be friendly to that guy, I guess,
SPEAKER_03: because Kiernan's never going
to be that. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Fun. As a
SPEAKER_03: player, I have scruples. As a
character, I am indifferent. As a
SPEAKER_03: character, you're a
murderhobo. I get it.
SPEAKER_02: Only when directed. Only when
directed. She's actually the
SPEAKER_02: not-murderhobo.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah.
SPEAKER_02: That would involve emotional
disconnection.
SPEAKER_01: Well, a murder bot is just I'm
blowing people up because that's what
SPEAKER_01: guns do. I was told to aim my
SPEAKER_03: guns in that place.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah, like, honestly, I would
understand if you basically go send the
SPEAKER_01: associate to go kill the
SoulSec agent before he can transmit anything.
SPEAKER_03: Yeah, I'm not doing anything.
I could do everything. I could solve this
SPEAKER_03: problem in one way very
quickly, but... Right now, I was just like, hey,
SPEAKER_03: just letting you guys know. I
can solve all the problems
SPEAKER_02: super fast. And then we can
pull that chip right out of his head, and
SPEAKER_02: I can see what's on it.
SPEAKER_03: Kiernan was on that wavelength
when a security blip went off on the
SPEAKER_03: person we were watching. He
was very much like, we're going to go
SPEAKER_03: apprehend a person. And then
everyone was like, no, no, no, let's not.
SPEAKER_03: Well, we didn't know you were
going to walk up and be
SPEAKER_02: sassy bitches.
SPEAKER_03: Why are you saying that
Kiernan was anything in that?
SPEAKER_02: Because you were there?
SPEAKER_03: I was backed up. I did not say
words. I was silent. As the grave.
SPEAKER_02: Right, but you were
surrounding the guy. Like, your presence definitely
SPEAKER_02: was an influence. And you're
not exactly a mild-mannered-looking guy.
SPEAKER_03: All right. Did we want Zoey to
go alone? I understand I'm very lippy for
SPEAKER_03: a monkey in this society, all
right? That doesn't go for me. Did we want
SPEAKER_03: Zoey to go alone? Did we want
to know what would happen to Zoey if he
SPEAKER_03: had gone alone?
SPEAKER_01: I would say that Zoey's
nickname should be Gunface. Not because he
SPEAKER_01: shoots people, because
everyone wants to put a gun in his face.
SPEAKER_03: No, I think we should
definitely stick together. I think it was good
SPEAKER_03: that you stuck together.
SPEAKER_01: Honestly, it's why the guy
retreated without forcing an interaction.
SPEAKER_01: He wasn't going to shoot a
random person with who knows what weapons you
SPEAKER_01: guys had on. Yeah. Did
SPEAKER_01: people enjoy, though, their
first undersea adventure?
SPEAKER_00: None of us did.
SPEAKER_03: The seaweed is always greener.
I was waiting for
SPEAKER_03: a Jamaican crab to come around
and talk to us, but... I got to do
SPEAKER_03: crab RP over the whole boat. I
was doing my vac suit stuff. I was doing
SPEAKER_03: my climbing.
SPEAKER_01: I really hope I landed the
vibe of you guys being on the sub and
SPEAKER_01: controls and Getting the suits
on, and everyone has their little mission
SPEAKER_01: part.
SPEAKER_03: Oh yeah, I loved some of the
description stuff you were doing with how
SPEAKER_03: Vaxuit phenomena kind of work
out. The moment you started talking about
SPEAKER_03: that facet of the career, I
was already thinking of little...
SPEAKER_03: Not like folk phenomena, but
like common phenomena amongst...
SPEAKER_03: Operators of like, oh shit,
yeah, calm down, focus up, you
SPEAKER_03: know, the heat that you think
you're feeling from the ship is not real,
SPEAKER_03: like phantom heat and phantom
cold in environments where there is none
SPEAKER_03: of that. The training was fun,
like not assuming that the players were
SPEAKER_03: competent, but like that they
needed to be trained for the job. That was
SPEAKER_03: good stuff. Yeah, good stuff.
I really liked
SPEAKER_03: some of the ideas you floated
there, Patrick. Floating.
SPEAKER_03: Have a good night.
SPEAKER_02: I would say that not
everything that you had tonight landed very well.
SPEAKER_03: Good night. And a lot of good
nights.
SPEAKER_00: Womp womp. I don't know that I
got this fun, but sure.
SPEAKER_00: I'm glad you had a joke. I did
have fun, Patrick. The landing was purely
SPEAKER_00: a joke. All right. Good night.
Bye-bye. Good night.